[musique]
Thba debrial. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Je
m'appelle Thba de Montbrial, j'ai 57
ans. Je suis avocat depuis 31 ans. J'ai
créé en 2015 le centre de réflexion sur
la sécurité intérieure qui est le
thinking tang français sur les questions
de sécurité et de souveraineté au sens
le plus large et je suis par ailleurs
lieutenant colonel de la réserve
opérationnelle de la gendarmerie.
Donc mon colonel, la dernière fois qu'on
vous a reçu, c'était en 2018. Oui.
Euh l'histoire vous a absus.
La la situation française en terme de
sécurité, en terme de violence aux
personnes, en terme de d'élitement et de
d'effondrement pratiquement de nos
services publics face à cette lame de
fond, c'est ce tsunami de violence. On
va refaire le point et ensuite on va
faire une expérience de pensée pour
savoir où ça nous emmène si on prend pas
des mesures proactives. Ça vous va ? Ça
te va ? Ça me va.
Ça te va ? Ça te va ? Alors, qu'est-ce
que tu racontais en 2014 ?
En fait, j'ai j'étais avocat euh
pénaliste, plutôt engagé auprès des des
notamment des forces de l'ordre et
cetera, mais aussi beaucoup de pénales
des affaires. Bref, c'était un avocat
pénaliste classique pendant quasi
pendant pendant une grosse quinzaine
d'années. Et au tournant des années
2010-212,
par tous les capteurs que j'ai, j'ai
senti arriver la la vague d'islamiste.
Je me suis intéressé à l'islam radical.
J'ai un peu plus lu qu'avant. Avant,
c'était une culture de de surface. Je me
suis mis dedans et j'ai compris
notamment en lisant Alsouri qui a écrit
un bouquin qui s'appelle l'appel à la
résistance islamique mondiale en 2005
que et qui théorise tout ce qui se passe
et ce qui est en train de se passer que
euh nous l'Occident allions être l'objet
d'une véritable vague de de conquête
idéologique et pour partie militaire.
Militaire dans la dans la dans le mode
opératoire, hein. C'est pas militaire au
sens la la Grande Guerre où les gens
déboulent à à 500000. Euh à partir du
moment où euh un certain nombre de
jeunes occidentaux et notamment français
ou vivants en France sont allés en Syrie
euh puisqueévidemment qui part
reviendra. Ça c'est mathématique. Et
Alouri avait théorisé qu'une guerre
civile qui permettrait à de jeunes
musulmans européens de s'aguérir allait
permettre d'accélérer le phénomène de
conquête islamique de l'Europe. Donc
là-dessus, j'ai commencé euh à en parler
avec mes capteurs dans les services de
renseignement, dans dans les
préfectures, dans les parquets et
cetera. Et j'ai compris que un, le truc
était en train d'arriver et que de il y
a très peu de gens en France qui
l'avaient compris euh pour deux raisons.
D'abord, il y a le déni. C'estàd qu'il y
a des gens qui considèrent que tout ça
c'est pas possible, que c'est
formidable, on est le pays des droits de
l'homme, que qui voudrait nous en
vouloir et cetera, qu'en plus c'est un
peu fachaud sur les bord de penser ça.
Et ensuite parce que bah il y a le biais
de normalité, c'est-à-dire que on est en
paix à l'époque depuis 70 ans, il y a
des il y a des crises mais globalement
la France est en 2013-24 sans doute l'un
des pays dans lequel dans toute
l'histoire de l'humanité il aura fait le
plus bon vivre. Et donc euh je me lance
un peu comme un lanceur d'alerte sur le
sujet et alors au début les gens me
regardent comme ça. Il y a des scènes,
il y a des scènes parfois un peu
surréalistes. Et puis arrive Charlie le
7 janvier 2015 et là je me souviens par
exemple le 7 janvier 2015 au soir, je
suis sur l'antenne de BFM et il y a une
des journalistes les plus connues de
l'antenne qui a les larmes aux yeux qui
se tourne vers moi pendant une page de
pub et qui me dit "Thbo avais raison."
Et à partir de là euh non pas que je
doutais malheureusement d'avoir eu
raison, mais je me suis dit que c'était
en quelque sorte un vrai combat qui
commençait et à partir de de de du début
de de ces attaques, fin 2014, début
2015, j'ai créé le centre de réflexion
sur la sécurité intérieure à ce
moment-là, il y a 10 ans. Aujourd'hui,
ils sont il a grandi, il s'est développé
et il traite, comme je disais tout à
l'heure, de de tous les sujets de
souveraineté. Mais ce qui m'a fait
passer le cap et sortir du mon stricte
métier d'avocat, c'est vraiment cet
engagement au départ contre euh
l'islamisme. Ensuite, bah il y a eu la
vague 2015-208 globalement d'attentat
euh de terroristes islamistes. Euh
ensuite, ça a un tout petit peu euh ça
ça s'est un peu atténué dans le rythme.
Et paradoxalement, ce qui est encore
plus inquiétant si on fait le bilan
aujourd'hui, c'est que l'islamisation de
la société sur le plan idéologique,
c'est considérablement
aggravé. Et pour finir le tableau,
on a vu à partir de la crise sanitaire,
il y a eu un un un vrai changement avec
une augmentation de l'accès une
augmentation de l'accélération de la
délinquence. C'est-à-dire que la France,
comme le reste des pays d'Europe, mais
plus que beaucoup d'autres, a vu sa
délinquence et en particulier sa
délinquence violente euh se développer,
exploser. Et on est aujourd'hui, pour
lancer le débat euh un pays extrêmement
affaibli, dont les structures
institutionnelles sont affaiblies, dont
les politiques sont massivement
rejetées, ça c'est très important d'en
avoir conscience, et qui est attaqué,
miné par deux contrecultures qui
prennent la place. parce que la nature a
horreur du vide. La première, c'est la
grande criminalité organisée qu'on
appelle parfois un peu facilement le
narcotrafic mais qui est loin de se
contenter du narcotrafic.
Et la deuxième, c'est l'islamisme. On
n'est pas les seuls. Il y a les anglais,
il y a les Belges. La plupart des pays
européens sont concernés, mais les
anglais et les Belges sont sont encore
plus mal en point que nous. Et pour
couronner le tout, il y a eu le 7
octobre 2023. Et pour moi, le 7 octobre
2023, c'est vraiment ce que ce que les
Américains appellent un game changer. Un
game changer, c'est un événement qui
change complètement les données du jeu.
Pourquoi ça change les données du jeu ?
Parce que pour la première fois,
le jour même, l'après-midi même, dans
l'esprit de tous les islamistes et d'une
manière générale de tous ceux qui
détestent l'Occident, la défaite de
l'Occident est devenue quelque chose de
possible. Pourquoi ? Parce que Israël,
ce mythe sécuritaire, technologique, de
renseignement efficace et cetera,
s'était fait submergé par un certain
nombre de types qui vivaient dans la
bande de Gaza et qui étaiit considéré
comme étant complètement contenu et qui
ont réussi à monter une opération
militaire qui a été un massacre mais qui
techniquement est une opération
militaire complètement sous des radars
qui étaient pourtant présents. Et ce
jour-là, on a vu partout la le ça a
galvanisé si tu veux, ça a galvanisé les
les tout tous ceux qui nous détestent et
le la cerise sur le gâteau si j'ose dire
et la vraie mauvaise nouvelle, c'est que
un parti politique français qui est la
France insoumise s'est saisi de ce
phénomène en utilisant à fond la carte
euh de l'islamophilie que je définis par
l'amitié et la séduction envers les
réseaux islamistes et d'une manière plus
générale avec beaucoup d'ambiguïé envers
les les réseaux musulmans.
Vous avez des preuves de ça ? Tu as des
preuves de ça ?
Ah bah il y a tous les bouquins qui ont
été écrits, la secte, l'histoire de
l'anticutisme, il y a le procès qui a
été gagné l'autre jour par Raphael
Enoven et Richard Malka. Et puis il
suffit de de regarder, il suffit de
documenter, il suffit de regarder Rima
Hassan. C'est c'est ce que je je j'ai
écris un livre qui s'appelle le choc ou
la chute. Je sais que tu l'as lu
puisqu'il est juste devant toi. Donc euh
je le vois. Euh on va en parler dans ce
livre. Je fais tout un chapitre sur le
tournant que constitue euh le le 7
octobre et la façon dont de façon
tangible et avec tous les codes, avec
les codes visuels, avec les codes
sémantiques, euh la la France insoumise
joue ce jeu de de la duplicité avec les
islamistes. Et quand tu vois Rima Hassan
qui le jour de le soir de l'élection
européenne en juin 2024 est à droite ou
à gauche d'ailleurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avec le Kéfier, avec toute la
campagne où elle n'a pas dit un mot sur
l'Europe ou peut-être par accident, mais
par contre elle a été elle a rabâché
Gaza, les génocides de tout ce qui peut
alimenter l'antisémitutisme. Et ben on a
aujourd'hui le pire des situations,
c'est que on a un islamisme qui est
galvanisé dans un pays de plus en plus
violent et avec une récupération par une
force politique d'extrême gauche qui
malheureusement pèse dans notre pays.
Donc je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Jean-Luc Müenchon, il est en train de se
faire auditionner. Euh qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce que tu as comme preuve pour
dire la la France insoumise euh fraye
avec l'islamisme ? Parce que entendre ça
comme ça sans avoir de contexte, c'est
mettre toute la France insoumise dans le
même sac ou c'est que des acquintances
de de certains ou qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Ah bah c'est c'est au-delà de la
question des acquaintances de certains.
C'est une ligne politique qui
qui a des acquitances selon vous selon
toi
dans à la France insoumise ? Ah bah déjà
Rima Hassan, ça c'est documenté puisque
Rima Hassan est allé en Jordanie
au
je vais dire elle a le droit d'aller en
Jordanie.
Ah ben je finis la phrase au aux
obsèques de de de l'un des des chefs du
Hamas de Sinoir. Donc à partir de là euh
c'est déjà en soi c'est c'est déjà en
soi révélateur. Ensuite
c'était en son nom à titre personnel à
titre professionnel en terme député.
D'abord elle était pas seule. Il il y
avait d'autres gens de la France
insoumise avec elle. Euh et et ensuite,
elle a très largement médiatisé cette
présence sur les réseaux sociaux. Et
puis il y a tous les codes, c'est-à-dire
que si vous prenez la tweet liste de de
Rima Hassan, elle n'arrête pas de faire
des clins d'œil, des allusions, des
sous-entendus. On est en permanence sur
cette ligne sur cette ligne qui est qui
qui qui est une ligne très clairement
si c'est des clins d'œil, des
sous-entendus, c'est peut-être toi qui
l'interprète mal. Alors, dans ce cas-là,
on est nombreux puisque euh tu as euh
les les livres, il y a il y a un certain
nombre de livres qui ont été écrits. Il
y a le livre La secte sur la France
insoumise. Il y a le livre dont le titre
m'échappe depuis 5 minutes mais euh sur
l'antisémitisme qui est euh qui qui est
qui qui reprend tous les points, euh
tous les comportements, tous les
discours, toutes les présences à des
manifestations diverses et variées de
gens de la France insoumise au soutien
de d'une ligne antisémite et des livres
qui n'ont pas été attaqués en justice.
Ce qui est quand même ce qui est quand
même extrêmement intéressant.
Il peut-être pas vu sortir le lit.
Il ont peut-être pas vu sortir et
peut-être qu'il regarde pas la télé et
qu'il regarde pas les réseaux sociaux.
C'est c'est une hypothèse mais c'est une
hypothèse. Et
tu comprends en tant qu'avocat pourquoi
je me fais l'avocat du diable ?
Ah non mais on est là pour on est là
pour en débattre, il y a aucun problème.
Mais ce sont pour moi des des faits qui
sont aujourd'hui acquis au débat public.
d'abord par la multiplicité des sources
qui qui euh euh qui recensent tous ces
événements, toutes ces photos euh toutes
ces prises de parole et par le fait que
un la plupart du temps, il y a pas
d'attaque en justice et deux, quand il y
a des attaques en justice, elles sont
gagnées par ceux qui se défendent et par
ceux qui disent ce que je suis euh en
train de dire. des exemples qui ont
gagné
et ben l'autre jour ce que j'ai dit il y
a il y a quelques minutes, c'est-à-dire
le procès gagné euh euh la il y a il y a
la semaine dernière je crois où il y a
que un peu plus par Raphael Entoven qui
était défendu par Richard Malka et
Richard Malka d'ailleurs donc l'avocat
qui est aussi l'avocat de Charlie qui a
qui en a fait qui a fait un livre qui a
publié sa plaido qui a fait un petit un
petit bouquin où il y a sa plaido et
dans sa plaido tu pourras inviter
Richard Malka dans sa plaido il y a
toutes sortes d'exemples.
C'est important de de toujours se faire
l'avocat du diable pour tester le
raisonnement de l'autre, ses sources
parce que on peut pas si si j'étais si
j'étais pas prêt à si j'étais pas prêt à
débattre, je serais pas venu.
Bon, tu sais tu sais que je peux être
dur de temps en temps. Euh revenons à
nos moutons. La violence en France.
Ouais.
Les chiffres depuis qu'on s'est luis
2018, ils sont passés de quoi à quoi ?
Les chiffres ont explosé. On avait une
tendance qui est qui qui qui était déjà
à l'augmentation depuis depuis quelques
années parce que la la
politique, le choix de François Hollande
de prendre Christian Tobira comme garde
des saut est probablement des un des
pires choix politiques des ces 30
dernières années. Et donc d'abord, on a
pris beaucoup de retard en matière
judiciaire, en matière pénitenciiaire,
mais d'une manière générale, la violence
n' n'a pas cessé d'augmenter. Ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui, c'est que on atteint
des chiffres qui sont totalement
inédits. Alors, quand on parle de ça, je
je je coupe avant que tu me poses la
question, il y a des gens qui disent
"Ouais, mais la France ça reste quand
même beaucoup moins violent que il y a
150 ou 200 ans." Bah, je rajoute "Ouais,
c'est vrai que c'est aussi moins violent
qu'au Moyen-Âge, c'est sûr." Mais la
comparaison aujourd'hui, c'est pas par
rapport au Moyen-Âge. La comparaison,
c'est sur les 50 dernières années et euh
sur sur ce qui se passe dans dans
d'autres pays européens ou aux
États-Unis. Et là, ce qu'on voit sur les
chiffres, c'est une véritable explosion
puisque par exemple, on est euh en 2024
à 14 meurtres et tentatives de meurtre
par jour. C'est-à-dire que il y en a
plus de tous les 2 heures. Il y a une
agression physique toutes les 3 minutes.
Il y a un policier ou un gendarme qui
est blessé. toutes les 20 minutes, les
homejacking, les agressions à domicile
qui est quelque chose dont on parle
assez peu, on commence à en parler un
peu plus mais qui est terrifiant hein,
c'est les gars qui débarquent chez toi
euh et qui s'emprennent à toi, à ta
famille, à ta femme, à tes filles et
cetera. Donc c'est vraiment l'horreur
hein, c'est pour moi la sans doute le
comble de l'horreur. Les homejacking, il
y en a eu 550 l'année dernière et euh en
région parisienne il y en a il y en a à
peu près trois par semaine. Et c'est une
tendance qui est en augmentation
constante avec des équipes qui sont de
plus en plus éclatées, des équipes
d'auteur, des criminels qui sont de plus
en plus éclatés, qui sont recrutés sur
Snapchat qui est devenue une agence
intérim, l'agence intérim du crime par
des mecs qui créent donc qui montent les
les
c'est pas Snapchat qui est venu l'agence
d'intérim, c'est c'est
qui est utilisé comme une agence oui qui
est utilisé
Snapchat. Non mais c'est pas pardon,
c'est pas Snapchat dis, c'est devenu
vachement c'est devenu vachement
juridique chez toi.
J'essaie de parler grand public et
d'aller vite. Mais alors je recommence,
je reformule qu' sois pas attaqué par
Snapchat. La le réseau social Snapchat
qui est un réseau social utilisé par
plein de gens et en général assez jeunes
est un réseau qui est aujourd'hui
détourné, ça va détourné, utilisé en
tout cas par les criminels pour monter
des équipes sur sur des actions
d'opportunité.
Il y a pas que ce réseau là d'ailleurs.
Non mais c'est le plus utilisé
aujourd'hui. C'est ce que dit la police
judiciaire en tout cas. Donc vous avez,
tu as un mec euh qui est souvent au
Maghreb ou à Dubaï qui monte une équipe
euh qui est souvent alors pour le pour
l'Île-de-France, il y a beaucoup
d'équipes du 91 et du et du 95, c'est
les les deux grosses les deux gros
fournisseurs d'équipe. Euh très souvent
d'ailleurs des gens qui sont d'origine
africaine et qui montent sur des cibles
et qui rentrent dans les domiciles et ce
livre a toutes sortes d'exactions qu'on
qu'on peut qu'on peut imaginer. Donc ça
et ben euh aujourd'hui c'est une des
criminalités qui est à la mode. Et
puisqu'on parle des réseaux sociaux
puisqu'on a parlé de Snapchat, ce qui
est très intéressant, Snapchat c'était
pour parler de l'organisation des le
vecteur utilisé comme organisation par
les criminels. Mais de l'autre côté, du
côté des victimes, les ciblages se font
aussi par le biais de l'exposition que
les gens font de leur existence sur les
réseaux sociaux. plusieurs types de
cibles euh des gens qui à tort ou à
raison sont considérés euh comme ayant
de l'argent. On se souvient de la vague
d'agression contre les gens dans le
milieu de la des cryptoonnaies,
ce qui est toujours le cas.
Ce qui est toujours le cas. Euh mais il
y a une grosse équipe qui a été
démantelée il y a pas très longtemps,
mais c'est pas pour ça que ça s'est
arrêté. Euh une criminalité hyper
violente. Euh les euh influenceurs qui
sont de plus en plus ciblés. Euh on se
souvient de l'histoire épouvantable de
cette influenceuse marseillaise qui a
été agressée et violée chez elle au mois
de juillet. Euh, il y a une histoire que
j'ai vu passer il y a pas très longtemps
où un influenceur qui est qui est moins
connu du grand public et qui est à
l'étranger a vu son papa se faire
enlever en banlieu parisienne, torturé
et laisser pour mort
au bord de la forêt. Tout ça cétait il y
a quelques semaines hein. Donc tout ça
c'est ce sont vraiment des des
phénomènes qui sont de plus en plus de
plus en plus d'actualité et les gens
connu en général le ciblage de joueurs
de foot de d'artistes de journalistes
même. Donc les voilà les gens que les
voyou voient maintenant sur les réseaux
sociaux sont susceptibles d'être de ce
fait ciblés par des modes opératoires
qui utilisent aussi les réseaux sociaux.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, j'en profite que
tu sois avocat. Bon, imagine-toi, on est
chez toi dans ta maison de campagne, tu
es propriétaire d'un berger du Cocas kg
mâle,
relativement euh
tendu quand quelqu'un d'inconnu rentre
dans la maison. Et tu as un autre chien,
c'est un Doberman euh dans qui est
éduqué et dressé au gardien. H
on est en train de boire un whisky
tranquille chez toi devant ta cheminée
et il y a quelqu'un, une équipe qui
s'introduit
et comme ce sont des chiens bien élevés,
ils attendent que les gens soient bien
rentrés avant de rentrer en opération.
Le Doberman comme le Doberman
attrape à la carotide tout de suite.
Ouais.
À la jugulaire et le berger du Caucas à
la fémorale. Il y en a un, il finit en
charpis à la maison.
Ouais. Qu'est-ce qui se passe pour toi
et tes deux chiens ? Tes chiens sont
euthanasiers, tu es poursuivis en
justice. Les les mecs sont entrés armés
chez toi. Ils ont pas fait encore usage
de l'arme mais ils se font éventrer par
les deux chiens à la maison.
Le
Qu'est-ce qui est en tort ?
Bah les mecs, ceux qui sont rentrés chez
moi, de toute façon, attends, il faut
quand même remettre l'église au centre
du village. Je veux dire le le on va
répondre, on va on va revenir sur le
droit après. Mais moi, je fais partie
des gens euh qui sont nés avec un
certain bon sens et qui en plus ont lu
Cicéron, pas que mais notamment. Et si
c'est rond dit que la légitime défense,
le droit de se défendre proportionnel
est un droit naturel de l'homme. On va
parler ça de proportionnel. C'est c'est
comment déjà ? C'est quoi de quoi on
parle ? Le droit de se défendre c'est un
droit naturel de l'homme qui d'ailleurs
est en droit introduit dans tous les
systèmes judiciaires. Tous des pays
libres, des pays des pays qui ne le sont
pas. Il y a toujours la légitime défense
est toujours prévue. Après, il y a il y
a tout un tas de modalités.
Premièrement. Deuxièmement, en France,
il y a une évolution que je regrette,
que j'ai beaucoup combattu, que je
continue à combattre. J'en parle encore
plusieurs pages consacrées d'ailleurs à
la question de la doctrine du château à
laquelle on va venir dans dans ce livre.
C'est comment est-ce queen France on
peut se défendre aujourd'hui ? Ce que je
regrette, c'est que petit à petit la
jurisprudence, c'est-à-dire la façon
dont le droit est interprété par les
juges, a restreint en pratique ce droit
de se défendre qui est plutôt bien
rédigé dans la loi. Le texte est plutôt
bien fait. C'est l'article L225 du code
pénal pour ceux qui voudront s'y référer
avec deux cas de présomption,
c'està-dire d'inversion de la charge de
la preuve qui sont prévus dans l'article
122 6 forcément celui d'après, dont
celui qui évoque le cas que tu viens de
de mettre en scène, c'est-à-dire
l'intrusion dans un lieu habité de gens
par la violence ou la ruse ou la
contrainte. Et simplement le texte dit
de nuit. Alors déjà moi je mite pour que
ce soit 24 he sur 24 parce que quand tu
es chez toi posé pe pénard, tu es dans
ton avre de paix. C'est là que tu
décompresses et tu il y a pas il y a pas
de grande différence à faire entre le
jour et la nuit premièrement. Ensuite le
maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
ce cas-là ? En pratique malheureusement
la les décisions des tribunaux donc la
jurisprudence a à a à émasculé à vider
de son sens cette présomption. Et on
demande toujours à celui qui fait usage
de la force de euh justifier de la
nécessité et la proportionnalité de euh
son action. Mais le problème c'est que
quand quelqu'un un voyou ou des voyou
rentre chez toi le jour, la nuit peu
importe, tu es peinard,
tu es pas prêt. Tu regardes la télé, tu
lis un bouquin, tu es au coin du feu
avec un whisky comme tu disais.
tu vis ta meilleure vie, tu es en
famille,
tout à coup ça déboule.
Donc on se retrouve dans si on fait une
analogie militaire pour paraphraser
Claus Vit une seconde avec une triple
infériorité. L'ennemi a choisi le lieu,
le moment et les moyens
et toi tu es baisé.
Donc pour sortir de cette infériorité
tactique, tu es obligé de surmonter
toutes ces difficultés qui t'arrivent
dessus. Comment veux-tu dans ces cas-là
avoir la lucidité absolue d'être capable
de mesurer la proportionnalité, la
nécessité et cetera ? Moi, je pense que
dans ces cas-là, pour les domicile, il
faut créer une immunité de la réponse
pénale qui est c'est donc la doctrine du
château qui est une un concept juridique
qui vient des des Anglo-Saxons. C'était
une doctrine, je 17 ou 18e. L'idée
c'était de dire le le château de chaque
gentleman
est inviolable. D'accord ? Et ça existe
en Australie, ça existe aux États-Unis,
en Angleterre. Maintenant, ça a été
étendu, ça existe en Suède, en Italie.
Donc, c'est quelque chose qui qui se
développe beaucoup. L'idée, c'est de
dire que si on rentre chez toi
et qu'on te surprend chez toi, tu n'es
pas obligé d'attendre là, il va y avoir
un mot de droit qui est important. Tu
n'es pas obligé d'attendre comme
aujourd'hui de voir si tu as affaire à
des gens qui viennent commettre un
délit. Le délit, c'est le vol.
Excusez-moi, monsieur, je viens piquer
votre ordinateur
s'il vous plaît.
Ou s'il vous plaît ou un crime,
c'est-à-dire je vais violer ta femme, je
vais t'attacher au lit et te torturer
pour avoir le code du coffre. Sachant en
plus, c'est ça qui est terrible et qu'il
faut avoir à l'esprit parce qu'en fait
c'est le premier argument, il faut
expliquer les autres avant que les mecs
qui rentrent en fait, ils sont pas sûr
de ce qu'ils vont trouver. Et donc, il
peut y avoir le crime d'opportunité.
C'est quoi le crime d'opportunité ?
C'est le mec qui rentre chez toi pour
parce que on lui a dit, il a été
renseigné par un artisan qui est venu
par un mec et cetera et tu as des beaux
tableaux. Les gars, l'équipe il
rentrent, ils savent pas ce que c'est
que les tableaux mais on leur a dit les
tableaux c'est la commande, ils y vont
et puis euh tu es là alors que tu étais
pas prévu d'être là et puis ta fille de
15 ans elle était là et et elle était
pas prévue d'être là non plus. Voilà une
équipe qui va arriver pour commettre un
délit, c'est-à-dire le vol de tes
affaires et qui te voyant voyant ta
fille va basculer d'un coup en mode
crime.
Et donc si tu attends d'être attaché sur
ton lit à te faire tisonner la plante
des pieds pour te dire "Ah bah
maintenant que je suis en mode défense
contre un crime, j'ai le droit de me
défendre", ben non, ça marche pas comme
ça. La vraie vie, ça marche pas comme
ça. Tout ça pour dire que je milite et
je c'est un truc que je développe pas
mal dans mon livre. Je milite pour que
les gens aient le droit, ce qui ce qui
est du bon sens de euh se défendre quand
ils sont agressés chez eux. Donc
maintenant, j'en viens à Tclepse.
Donc c'est Écleps où c'est le tien et le
mien. Donc euh
Mondo Berman s'appelle Quartz. [rires]
Donc si je dis quartz attaque le le mien
s'appelle Benéie. Euh donc italien le
tien.
Le mien est italien.
Il est en calibre [rires] 12.
Le mien le mien est est musclé. Donc le
euh dans ces cas-là euh les chiens euh
n'ont fait que défendre euh la maison et
donc je moi je pense qu'il y a pas de
problème. Après ça veut pas dire
tu connais Mondoberman Doberman fait 54
kg euh il est il est éduqué à attraper à
la carotide. C'estàd qu'il est pas
éduqué à apprendre au mordant l'objectif
c'est le sang. Oui mais
donc si je l'envoie est-ce que je suis
considéré armé pas armé ? Mon chien va
être abattu pas abattu. C'est une
expérience de pensée bien entendu. Tu
es pas considéré comme armé. Maintenant,
je te déconseille euh d'aller si tu une
fois une fois l'affaire entendue et une
fois que tu auras le plaisir d'être
vivant parce que c'est quand même
l'objectif numéro 1, quand tu seras
entendu par la police ou la gendarmerie,
tu es pas obligé de dire que tu as
dressé ton chien à attaquer à la
carotide. Il est éduqué.
Il est Oui. éduqué.
Oui, mais tu peux dire "Bon, mon chien
il est il est éduqué à à défendre la
famille. Pas obligé de rentrer dans les
détails, tu vois. Le après encore c'est
une question de bon sens. c'est l'avocat
l'avocat en moi qui qui prend qui prend
toute sa place à la seconde. Mais il
faut il faut se on a le droit aussi de
se défendre judiciairement. Mais d'une
manière générale, ce qui est important,
c'est que les gens qui nous regardent
euh sachent que euh d'abord ils ont le
droit de se défendre, ça existe. Euh
qu'ensuite bah il faut être bien défendu
une fois qu'on est vivant et que
l'action est est terminée. c'est que en
toute hypothèse, moi je porte vraiment
le le message, mais ça fait longtemps
parce que c'est quelque chose que j'ai
déjà abordé dans mon précédent bouquin
en 2020, ce message qu'il faut
absolument changer la loi pour que les
gens qui sont agressés, moi je vais plus
loin déjà, il y a la doctrine du château
dont on vient de parler et je pense même
que il faut mettre comme en droit
allemand et en droit suisse une une
excuse de
une excuse de frayeur, c'est-à-dire
C'estàd que les gens qui sont attaqués,
même dans la rue qui ben ils sont ils
sont terrifiés et donc s'ils ont une
sils surréagissent alors dans des
proportions raisonnables évidemment si
si le mec vous insulte et que vous le
décapitez ça va être excessif. Mais euh
s'il y a une surréaction dans des
proportions raisonnables et qui peuvent
se comprendre par je crois que ça
s'appelle l'excuse de saisissement en en
droit suisse mais qui peut se comprendre
par la frayeur que que vous avez eu euh
à ce moment-là et je je voilà je pense
que ça c'est des choses qu'il faut
introduire dans le droit. Pourquoi pour
finir ? Très important parce que la
police et la gendarmerie elles peuvent
pas être partout tout le temps.
Surtout à la campagne.
Surtout à la campagne. Et c'est pas
forcément une faillite de l'État. On va
parler après des moyens qui sont
insuffisants, mais même sans la question
de l'insuffisance des moyens, par
définition, on peut pas et heureusement
mettre un policier derrière chaque
citoyen. Euh et donc forcément le
criminel essaie quand même d'être un peu
malin et de commettre son forfait à un
moment où il a pris quelques précautions
et où il pense que il va pas y avoir de
policiers de gendarme dans les minutes
qui viennent. Donc dans ces cas-là, on
est livré à soi-même et il faut que le
droit permette de se défendre. Revenons
sur notre expérience de de pensée.
Imaginez un cas
juste pour l'expérience de pensée.
Monderman quartz euh je l'envoie parce
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui nous surprend.
Le mec est un peu costaud, je l'envoie
direct. Je lui dis arbite,
il y va. Bon, le problème c'était un
pauvre gars qui crevait la faim qui
venait me faire le frigo. Il venait
juste pour le frigo. Bon, résultat des
courses, il a perdu 18 L de sang. Il est
en train de giser dans son il est en
train de d'agoniser dans son sang.
C'est c'est c'est vraiment
Est-ce que la Est-ce que ma ma réaction
est proportionnelle, la légitime défense
est proportionnelle ou pas du tout ? Ou
j'aurais dû demander que mon chien lui
demande ses papiers avant et ses
intentions ? Comment ça ? Tu comprends
ce que je veux te dire ? L'exemple que
tu donnes, il illustre en fait
exactement ce que j'ai dit il y a 2
minutes. C'est-à-dire que quand tu es
dans cette situation, tu ne peux pas
attendre de connaître les intentions de
ceux qui rentrent chez toi pour une très
bonne raison. D'abord, elles
s'inscrivent dans le futur. Par
définition, tu ne le connais pas. Et
ensuite, ses intentions peuvent changer
par la criminalité d'opportunité. Encore
une fois, le mec vient te voler, c'est
un délit, il dit "Oh moi je suis pas
violent, je viens juste prendre." Et
puis tout à coup bah il voit ta fille et
il se dit "Ah bah tiens, je vais je vais
la violer." Bah il change, il switch et
et et même si t'a dit 5 minutes avant,
alors on est vraiment dans l'expérience
de pensée parce qu'en général il y a
quand même pas des des grands échanges
que bouge pas, je viens juste voler et
ben il a changé d'avis. Et si c'est que
si te se dit tiens toi tu as tu as l'air
bien portant, bien nourri puis tu as une
belle montre et donc finalement bah je
vais m'occuper de toi. Une fois qu' une
fois que tu es attaché ou assommé, bah
c'est trop tard. Donc la question c'est
d'où l'intérêt de de cette doctrine du
château et qui fait que les honnêtes
gens les hê gens ont le droit de se
défendre. C'est
une autre question. Imagine-toi euh
Quartz ne l'a pas terminé. Oui,
il a à peigne et gratiné et graté une
morsure paralysante. C'est que en plus
il saigne même pas. Si je l'attache en
attendant les forces de l'ordre, est-ce
que j'ai le droit ? J'ai pas le droit.
Ah oui, bien sûr. Ce qu'il faut
c'est pas considéré comme séquestration.
Non non non non non. Alors attends, il
faut que les choses soient claires.
D'abord autant je viens de développer,
on vient de développer quand même
abondamment le fait que moi je suis en
faveur mais fortement. C'est quelque
chose que je porterai et que je
porterai.
Ce n'est pas le cas de la loi à l'heure
actuelle. C'est c'est le cas de nuit et
dans un et et dans des conditions qui
sont contraintes, c'estàd qui sont
limitées par la jurisprudence,
c'est-à-dire par la somme des décisions
des des tribunaux. Mais ça veut pas dire
que c'est impossible. Et de toute façon,
la priorité c'est de rester vivant. Donc
les gens qui nous regardent, il faut
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils peuvent si
possible
en nétant pas excessif dans leur repost.
Mais le but c'est quand même de se
protéger premièrement. Deuxièmement, et
là on en vient à la à la à la à la à la
question que tu viens de poser et il
faut que les gens écoutent très
attentivement cette partie qui est
essentielle quel que soit les
circonstances, la violence qui aura été
subie ou exercée ou les deux subis et
exercé. Une fois que la scène est figée,
ce qu'on appelle une scène figée, c'est
les auteurs soit sont partis, soit sont
neutralisés, vivant ou mort, neutralisé,
hors de combat. À ce moment-là, ce qui
est très très important, c'est un de
prévenir tout de suite, pas d'attendre
prévient, on fait le 17 et on dit voilà
ce qui vient de se passer et on décrit
le mieux possible.
Ensuite ou concomitamment, on soigne.
Donc ça c'est très important. Dans ta
question, tu me dis est-ce que je peux
attacher le gars ? La réponse est oui
puisqu'il a été dangereux. Donc s'il est
assommé, sil est mal en point mais
toujours vivant, en l'attachant, tu te
prémunis de ce que au moment où tu vas
téléphoner et que tu tournes le dos, il
te réagresse mais pour autant tu dois le
soigner. Ça c'est très les deux choses,
c'est vraiment alerter, secourir. Ça
c'est très très important. Quel que soit
le choc, faut essayer he après le choc
et cetera, ça c'est tout un tas de
choses qui qui qui sont compliquées à
gérer. Mais c'est très important. Et je
peux même donner un conseil puisque tu
aller longuement sur ce sujet, c'est que
euh je pense que si on a des raisons de
penser qu'il y a une agression qui vient
de commencer à force si on en a la
preuve des gens qui sont rentrés, un
bruit de verre euh qui a cassé euh
éventuellement l'alarme et cetera. Bon
bref, un enfant qui dit "Papa, il y a
quelqu'un".
Quoi que ce soit, le premier truc à
faire, le premier truc à faire c'est de
faire le 17. Les appels 17 sont
enregistrés.
ou le 112. Oui, oui, pardon, j'ai le
réflexe. Le mieux, c'est le 112 parce
que le numéro européen et et qui et qui
aboutit aux pompiers, aux policiers et
cetera, qui va au au mieux au plus vite.
Donc le de tout à fait raison le 112. Et
le 112 des appels sont enregistrés.
intérêt énorme. Tu poses le tu poses le
combiné après s'il y a besoin, tu le
gardes si tu peux, mais sinon tu le
poses. Et tout ce que tu vas faire, tout
ce que tu vois, d'abord, tout ce que tu
vois, tu le dis et tu dis "Monsieur
sortez, sortez, il y a trois mecs très
vite tu essayes de les décrire. Tu
décris pourquoi ?" Parce enregistré. Si
après ça continue, il y aura la il y
aura la description qui sera enregistrée
et le jour venu s'il y a un procès qui
sera diffusé dans la salle d'audience.
Si les mecs savent tout de suite que ils
sont que les éléments d'identification
sont donnés sur le champ, et ben à ce
moment là ça tu as une vraie chance que
les gens s'en aillent déjà et s'ils s'en
vont pas et ben en tout cas ça va faire
arriver beaucoup plus vite les secours.
Et dernier avantage qui en lien avec
l'histoire la question de se défendre
c'est que tout ce que tu es contraint de
faire ou tu vas être contraint de faire
pour te défendre tu l'annonces. Donc si
tu as un fusil de chasse, tu dis tu dis
dégager, je suis armé, j'ai un fusil de
chasse, dégager, ne m'obligz pas à tirer
des trucs comme ça. Et sur la bande
comme ça, ça imprime. Et puis si ensuite
bah tu dois faire ce que tu as à faire
et ben le le scénario sera complètement
objectivé par cet enregistrement. Moi
c'est vraiment un conseil quand on me
pose la question en détail. Je savais
pas qu'on allait le faire ce soir mais
tu savais pas de quoi on allait parler ?
Non
non. Puis c'est que le début donc je me
dis qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui va arriver
après ? On a déjà été au Doberman et
tout ça. Mais donc euh ça c'est vraiment
important. C'est un conseil pour ceux
qui nous regardent. Ça c'est vraiment du
conseil opérationnel. Le 112, le 17, le
18, bon mais le mieux c'est le 112 ça
concentre les appels et on annonce tout
tout ce qu'on va faire. Mais il faut
avoir un plan. Dernier truc c'est un peu
le le le moi j'étais para c'est un peu
le l'ancien militaire qui parle euh dans
la France d'aujourd'hui
vu la violence qui explose vu les
risques et je pense qu'on va en parler
euh qui peut y avoir l'avenir avec des
peut-être des une criminalité qui
aboutissent à une perte de contrôle
partiel du territoire pendant quelques
heures ou quelques jours. Il faut que
les gens soient résilients, se préparent
à un certain nombre de scénarios
difficiles, que ce soit des accidents,
des catastrophes industrielles ou
climatiques et donc de la grande
délinquence. Et donc il faut aujourd'hui
dans la France d'aujourd'hui, c'est des
choses dont il faut parler en famille.
Il faut dire voilà si se passe si
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Voilà Petit A,
les mecs rentrent, on va où ? Je pense
qu'il faut avoir un point de repli. Il
faut avoir une safe room comme on dit.
C'est-à-dire un endroit où on peut se
réfugier tous ensemble, se barricader en
attendant la police ou la gendarmerie.
Tout ça c'est des choses importantes.
Tu as pas le droit de piéger ta maison
ta maison ?
Non.
Tu peux pas brancher tes poignées de
porte sur le 220 V. C'est interdit. Si a
un cambrioleur qui rentre et qui se fait
frire la la gueule parce que tu as
branché tes poigners de porte sur c'est
des questions compliquées parce que ça
va dépendre de tout un tas de choses.
Mais moi je je vais peut-être te
surprendre mais je vais te te
déconseiller ça pour une raison très
simple. c'est qu'un jour c'est ton gamin
qui rentre de boîte de nuit alors que tu
penses queil était parti se coucher et
qu'il sera sorti par la fenêtre euh qui
va rentrer euh un peu torché euh et qui
va oublier et qui du coup c'est lui qui
va se faire frire. Donc euh il faut les
les trucs compliqués et les trucs
compliqués, il faut pas les faire et il
faut penser que que le risque premier
c'est d'avoir un accident complètement
stupide. C'est pareil avec les armes à
feu, les armes de chasse et cetera. Il
faut faire, c'est bien d'en avoir, il
faut en avoir. Moi, je pense que c'est
quelque chose dans la France
d'aujourd'hui qui est important. Mais
d'abord, il faut savoir s'en servir.
C'est il vaut mieux ne pas avoir d'armes
qu'avoir une arme dont tu sais pas te
servir. Ça c'est très très important. Et
ensuite, c'est une éducation pour tout
le monde et c'est un plan. Donc les
plans de défense doivent être discutés
et il faut pas prendre de risque. Faut
jamais oublier une chose, c'est que en
cas de grande violence ou même de petite
violence d'ailleurs pour les gens qui
sont pas habitués, l'être humain va
perdre instantanément une partie
non négligeable de ses capacités
neuromusculaires et que donc la faculté
de jugement et la capacité d'action vont
être entravés. Donc tout ce qui va bien
quand on est bien au chaud et que si on
commence à faire des plans compliqués et
cetera, tout ça ne marchera plus le jour
où le palpitant va monter à 200 d'un
coup et où on va rentrer passer en mode
reptilien, survie et cetera. Et donc le
le c'est c'est quand même dommage euh de
transformer sa maison euh en en en camp
défensif euh de haute intensité et de se
retrouver avec un de ses enfants blessés
ou tués euh par euh par euh de de ce
fait. Franchement, je pense que
priorité, il faut quand même faire faut
quand même faire bien attention à sa
famille. La protéger, c'est bien. C'est
bien, mais faut pas se retrouver dans
les dans des choses trop compliquées.
Donc pas de mine antichar dans le
jardin, ni de mine antipersonnelle dans
le jardin.
Non.
Bon, pour une dernière petite question,
imagine-toi, on était tous les deux
tranquilles, il y a il y a une bande de
6 qui rentre vraiment très agressif,
vraiment très méchant, vraiment très
armé.
Je je te mets devant.
Oui. Non mais oui, c'est normal. C'est
normal. là tu sais que je serais
beaucoup plus létal que toi mon ami. Et
si par exemple je me fais cartonner un
peu, ça m'énerve un peu et là je passe
en mode diable, c'est-à-dire que je les
neutralise tous
et j'ai décidé de m'en torturer un. J'ai
le droit, j'ai pas le droit.
Alors, tu as le droit de les neutraliser
dès lors que
Non, mais pour le faire parler, s'il y
en a pas d'autres qui arrivent, tu
comprends ?
Je te réponds. Tu as le droit de
neutraliser tous ceux qui sont dangereux
tant qu'ils sont dangereux. 1 2 3 6 10
50 peu importe. Tant qu'ils sont
dangereux. à partir du moment où ils ne
sont plus dangereux. C'est où l'action
la menace qu'il constitue a cessé. La
phrase juridique, c'est ça. À partir du
moment où la menace a cessé, à ce
moment-là, toute violence est prohibée
et il n'est pas question de torturer
quiconque queles que soient les
justifications.
D'accord. Mais admettons, on est dans
mon village et qu'ils ont décidé de se
faire tout le village,
j'ai pas le droit de lui poser deux
trois questions d'une façon un peu un
peu invasive pour savoir s'il y a une
deuxième équipe qui arrive.
Le le la réponse juridique à cette
question est non.
Je répète, je répète, je répète la
réponse juridique à cette question est
non. Ensuite, la toute la question dans
l'hypothèse précise que tu donnes,
c'est-à-dire si on est dans une dans des
circonstances hyper dégradées et que on
est face à ce qui n'est manifestement
plus une agression, un homejacking, ce
dont on parlait jusqu'à maintenant, mais
quelque chose de beaucoup plus large.
Comprends pour ce sujet. Mais bien sûr,
parce que je c c'est des c'est des
sujets auxquels on a on a tous beaucoup
réfléchi quand on parle de question de
sécurité. C'est l'hypothèse euh que je
que j'évoque régulièrement et je suis
pas le seul euh de d'une action euh qui
serait euh une action de déstabilisation
de nature terroriste, mais qui serait
évidemment motivée par une idéologie ou
par une puissance étrangère pour
déstabiliser le pays et qui consisterait
à aller dans un village à tuer tout le
monde, à déclarer par exemple he puisque
c'est un scénario que j'ai déjà évoqué,
le khalifat dans le village et a appelé
tous les frères d'Europe à rejoindre
avec une petite vidéo sympa sur les
réseaux sociaux. Ça c'est un sujet qui
est un des cauchemars des des services
français. Dans ces cas là, si toi tu
sortais du resto et que tu te retrouves
face à une partie de l'équipe et que tu
tu es dans une dans un univers qui est
complètement dégradé, tu j'imagine que
la réponse à ta question, c'est tu fais
ce que tu as à faire. Mais euh on
s'éloigne dans ces cas-là euh en tout
cas momentanément des des questions
purement juridiques. On est je crois
dans une je dirais pour répondre qu'on
serait dans une espèce d'hyper cas de
force majeure euh
et où on est dans un cas vous saz pour
que les gens comprennent une une phrase
vaut mieux que 100. Euh si tu es le seul
à tirer dans une situation dégradée, bah
il y aura une enquête, tu seras emmerdé.
S'il y a 500 personnes qui tirent dans
les 10 premières minutes, il y aura
jamais d'enquête sur les 500 tirs.
Voilà. Donc c'est c'est ça ça donne ça
ça donne l'idée de de ce de ce à quoi de
de ce dont on parle. Un des un des
services de un des patrons des services
de renseignement israélien m'a dit il y
a pas très longtemps "My friend
très bien l'action israélien dis donc.
Je fais pas mal." Ouais. Il dit "My
friend we we have Gaza. You have Sand."
Et et si il m'a dit ça. Ouais. un mec
qui m'a dit ça et
quel quel niveau du renseignement
israélien
? Plus et il et et l'idée c'était de me
dire que si jamais il y avait un
événement qui par l'émotion qu'il génère
vienne
transcender tout ce qui fait que ça
n'arrive pas aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire
le côté rationnel business.
Les grands délinquants aujourd'hui, la
grande criminalité organisée qui a les
armes refusent de les passer aux petits
délinquants ou aux terroristes
islamiste. Pourquoi ? Parce que si elles
sont utilisées, à ce moment-là, il y
aura des grosses enquêtes
et tous les moyens de l'État qui seront
engagés et donc ça va empêcher le
déroulement du business pendant un
certain temps. C'est ce qui s'est passé
en 2023. Pourquoi est-ce qu'en 2023 dans
l'affaire Non mais je juste la phrase
pourquoi est-ce que dans l'affaire Naël
alors qu'on a eu une flambée de violence
inédite sur le territoire français, il y
a pas eu de tir à la calache sur les
policiers et les gendarmes, c'est pas
parce que les mecs avaient pas envie,
c'est parce qu'ils ont essayé de s'en
procurer et que la grande criminalité
organisée a dit niet.
Comment tu sais qu'ils ont essayé de
s'en procurer ?
Bon parce que il y a plein de il y a
plein de il y a il y a plein de gens là
police.
Tu connais les consignes de sécurité ici
?
pas d'énigrement et des sources carré
cubiques.
Des sources carré cubiques. Oui. Sources
carré cubique bleu
bleu.
Euh pour revenir à à ton agent de
renseignement israélien qui t'a fait le
parallèle douteux en
c sur le mode opératoire. Il est pas en
train de dire là encore par respect pour
la la rigueur de à laquelle tu me
rappelles et tu as raison, il est pas en
train il m'a jamais dit que tout le
département de la scène Saint-Denis
allait débouler dans Paris. C'est c'est
le c'est pas le sujet. Le sujet c'est
des phénomènes de masse. Un phénomène de
masse ça peut être à 50 à 100 à 200.
Quand le PSG gagne la Ligue des
Champions le 31 mai 2025, on a un
phénomène de masse qui en plus était
était quand même pas complètement une
surprise puisque la demi-finale contre
Arsenal 3 semaines avant se passe mal à
la sortie du stade et que donc les trois
dernières semaines avant la finale de la
Ligue des Champions sont consacrés à une
réflexion sur le thème quel plan de
sécurité on fait pour Paris et cetera.
Quelle anticipation les gars ! Et ben
n'empêche, on se fait déborder. Ah ça
c'est un truc moi qui
Mais 3 semaines avant vous foutez pas un
peu de l'égle du monde.
Oui, je suis d'accord. Non mais moi je
je le dis dans le livre he donc je peux
je le répète bien volontiers. C'est
quand même très curieux. Et le point
c'est que ça c'était déjà un phénomène
de masse même si un il était hyper
attendu et de il a eu lieu sans armes
même s'il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
qui ont pas forcément été rendues
publiques et qui rendent pas optimiste
pour l'avenir. Mais en tout cas, l'idée
d'une tout à coup d'un événement qui
crée une émotion, don je pense qu'elle
sera ethnique, culturelle ou religieuse
et qui déclenche un mouvement de masse,
ça c'est quelque chose aujourd'hui dont
plus que dont plus personne n'évacue
l'hypothèse au sein de l'appareil d'État
sécuritaire, ça c'est certain.
Je reviens je reviens sur je me fais
encore l'avocat. Euh la France
insoumise, ils sont pas tous en
incointance comme tu l' décrit. Il y a
des gens à la France insoumise qui
militent pour deux meilleurs droits pour
les jeunes, que tout le monde est à
manger à sa faim, qu'ils ont tous que
tout le monde est un toit pas trop cher
au-dessus de la tête. Ils sont pas tous
à mettre dans le même sac.
Oui.
Non,
peut-être. Mais à ce moment-là, c'est
moi qui a une question. C'est pourquoi
est-ce que ceux qui seraient simplement
dans cette logique d'une réflexion
certes idéologisé, mais ça c'est la vie
politique et c'est tout à fait le on
parfaitement le droit en démocratie et
heureusement, il faut que ça continue.
Ceux qui sont simplement dans une vision
de l'amélioration des conditions de vie
des autres et cetera, pourquoi est-ce
qu'il dénoncent pas tous ceux qui sont
partis en dérive ?
Il y en a qui ont dénoncé. Non.
Bah oui, c'est vrai, il y en a. Et ils
ont été ostracisés, exclus, bannis.
clouer au pilor, toutes les images que
tu veux. Intéressant.
Revenons à notre scénario euh on va dire
dégradé
d'un petit village français planqué dans
un département planqué et pas très bien
vascularisé en terme de de service
public et de de maintien de l'ordre.
Si ça commence à partir en quenouille
là-bas et que le temps d'intervention
c'est plus de 25 minutes, ça peut
la définition que tu viens de donner,
c'est partout en gros sauf en ville.
Euh dans ces cas-là,
tu vois la chose comment c'est l'armée
qui intervient, c'est les trois pauvres
gendarmes qui étaient dans leur brigade
en train d'essayer euh de de de résoudre
les problèmes de voisinage. Il
débarquent avec Ils ont quoi comme
pétard les gendarmes ? Ils sont des tout
petits pétards les les gens.
Ils ont le CIC 2022, le pistolet
automatique. Par contre maintenant, ils
ont tous ils ont tous des fusils
d'assaut. C'estàd que il y a Ah oui oui.
Dans les dans dans dans les véhicules de
gendarmerie, en tout cas dans les
brigades, il y a il y a plusieurs fusils
d'assaut qui peuvent être qui qui
peuvent être déployés assez vite. Et
dans les les psiges qui sont
l'équivalent des brigades
anticriminalité pour les les gendarmes,
euh il y a toujours au moins un véhicule
psy qui est de qui qui est de permanence
par département.
C'est oui, c'est mieux que rien. Euh je
c'est ils sont équipés ce qu'on appelle
équipé lourd. C'est une des grandes
avancées qu'on a obtenu à partir de 2016
que que je préconisais dans mon premier
livre en 2015, c'est-à-dire de tout de
suite comprendre que les primos
intervenants, c'est les gens qui
interviennent en premier sur une scène
de grande violence, c'est pas les
services spécialisés que sont le RAID,
le GIGN, la BRI. Ça c'est des services
qu'on appelle une fois que la situation
est identifiée comme étant de très haute
intensité. Mais ceux qui vont découvrir
le truc tout simplement lors d'une
patrouille en tombant dessus hein, c'est
souvent c'est comme ça et bien ce sont
les effectifs de sécurité publique,
c'est-à-dire police secours pour la pour
la police et la brigade de gendarmerie,
l'équipe qui est dans son kangou qui
tourne. Voilà. Et donc ces gens-là
seront les premiers au feu dans dans ces
cas-là. Donc ensuite bah il y a deux cas
de figures. Soit ils peuvent faire
quelque chose et tant mieux si c'est
quelque chose de s'ils sont face à une
situation qui est qui est qui est pas
qui qui ne les submerge pas dans tous
les sens du terme et s'ils ne peuvent
pas d'abord faut espérer queils auront
donné l'alerte. ce qui permettra quand
même d'avoir le nerf de la guerre, c'est
l'info, hein, donc c'est d'avoir de de
l'information le plus vite possible et
de l'info fiable. Parce que je fais une
parenthèse mais importante sur la
question, une question que beaucoup de
gens ne perçoivent pas, c'est que quand
il y a un événement dégradé,
comme chacun a un téléphone portable
aujourd'hui en France, tout le monde va
y aller de son film, de son témoignage,
va appeler, va saturer les services de
secours et du coup les infos qui vont
remonter vont apparaître contradictoire,
ce qu'on appelle le brouillard de la
guerre, c'est-à-dire qu'on on arrive
plus à savoir ce qui se passe et c'est
extrêmement difficile du côté des
États-majors, de faire le tri et de
savoir exactement ce à quoi on fait
face. C'est pour ça que dans l'armée,
comme dans la gendarmerie et dans la
police, on apprend he des il y a des
méthodes par radio pour passer des
messages, pour aller droit à l'essentiel
et pour donner tout de suite les les les
bons messages. Donc euh ça c'est très
important, on le sait, on le sait de
façon aigue. On en a une conscience
aigue euh depuis le 13 novembre au soir
puisque le 13 novembre au soir, il y a
beaucoup de reportages, on a eu les
commémorations des 10 ans il y a pas
très longtemps. Il y a eu beaucoup de
reportages qui ont montré hein les les
salves d'appel qui arrivaient dans les
centres d'appel euh et on voyait les
opérateurs posaient des questions pour
essayer de savoir si l'info qui arrivait
était euh le 15e témoignage pour la même
scène ou une scène différente. Mais il y
a eu plusieurs dizaines cette nuit-là.
Beaucoup de gens n'ont pas cette
perception. Il y a eu plusieurs dizaines
d'opérations de levée de doute. C'estàd
qu'il y a eu plusieurs et on a cru qu'il
y a eu plusieurs dizaines d'autres
attentats euh qui étaient euh qui
étaient en cours. Ce qui explique en
partie qu'une que que certaines des
forces été laissées en réserve comme ça
a pu parfois être mal compris et ce qui
était au contraire de de la de la bonne
politique de de garder des effectifs en
réserve parce qu'à partir du moment où
on avait de tr qu attaques, qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qui fait que on en aura pas 5
6 7 8 Voilà donc c'est normal de pas
mettre toutes ses forces et de pas
précipiter tout le monde sur sur la
première scène. En plus, si on n'a pas
pu interroger correctement le premier
qu'on a attrapé.
Ah ! Alors,
je reviens sur notre
radour ou 7 octobre,
c'est des scénarios qui sont
cogités, anticipés, préparés par nos
forces de l'ordre, nos services de
renseignement. Est-ce que tu en as eu
vent ? Est-ce qu'on t'en a parlé ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
senti ?
C'est une excellente question
et la réponse c'est ça dépend où et à
quel niveau.
Du côté on va partir de la base de la
pyramide. Les gens qui sont sur le
terrain, policiers, gendarme,
on les embrasse,
on les embrasse, on les embrasse tous
les jours. Tous les jours fort. Et ils
le savent.
Eux quand tu leur parles, ça fait 10 15
ans qu'ils te le disent. Donc eux à qui
au débat ? Ensuite, tu montes dans la
hiérarchie.
Il y a un espèce de phénomène humain que
j'ai pu observer tout au long de ma vie
en particulier sur Peter,
c'est non le principe de le principe de
Peter, c'est la compétence. C'est-à-dire
que plus tu montes plus plus tu montes
dans une dans dans une structure
hiérarchique, moins les gens sont bons.
Il y a beaucoup de choses à dire
là-dessus. C'est pas toujours vrai. Par
contre, c'est le principe que j'ai
appelé comme ça d'ailleurs dans mon
avant-dernier livre qui est du pas de
couille, pas d'embrouille. C'estàd que
plus tu montes un proverbe de Pierre
connaissable.
Ah ! Ah ouais ! Il devrait le bruffetter
ou il aurait dû le breu parce qu'il
aurait gagné beaucoup d'argent hein. Euh
le
on va faire des t-shirts.
Non mais c'est quelque chose qui est qui
c'est quelque chose d'ailleurs qui
s'applique on en parlera aussi à la
classe politique et cetera. C'est quand
même super intéressant parce que ce
principe c'est que quand tu arrives en
fin de carrière à à au poste les plus
haut qui te faisait rêver quand tu étais
jeune et parfois même tu n'y pensais
même pas parce que tu étais dans
l'action et cetera puis après tu
politises un peu, tu montes c'est
humain. Je critique absolument pas ça.
C'est complètement humain. Et souvent ce
qui ce qui va avec cette prise de
conscience et cette évolution, c'est que
tu as de moins en moins envie de donner
les mauvaises nouvelles au donneur
d'ordre politique parce que forcément le
politique va se retourner vers toi en
disant bah en gros démerdez-vous pour
que ça n'arrive pas. Euh alors tu du
coup tu demandes des budgets, on te dit
oui on en a pas donc soyez inventif tu
vois le truc compliqué.
Donc il vaut mieux lisser un peu la le
cette perception ce qu'il y a double
effet pervers. Il y a un effet pervers
le bas et un effet pervers vers le haut.
L'effet pervers le bas, c'est que du
coup il y a le risque que les effectifs
qui sont le plus qui qui seront au
contact bah soit euh moins bien moins
bien informé, moins bien informé, formé,
équipé et donc qu'il y ait une baisse de
morale et vers le haut c'est que les
politiques se disent "Bah c'est vrai que
ça va pas ça va pas si mal puisqu'on me
dit pas que ça va mal." Donc c'est un
double effet pervers.
Il y a un changement depuis quelques
temps. C'estàd que ce phénomène qui en
caricature he ça concerne évidemment pas
tout le monde mais ce phénomène qui
disons qui avait tendance quand même
assz à être assez présent qui était
autour des gens qui commençaient à
atteindre les gens qui avaient entre 45
et 55 ans selon les circonstances. En
gros encore une fois je au risque pardon
pour pardon pour ceux qui nous regardent
mais au risque de caricaturer un peu ce
phénomène. Il est en très nette
diminution. C'est-à-dire que on a
maintenant des chefs, y compris des
grands chefs,
quand je les vois parlent de ça sans
aucun sans aucune fausse pudeur et et et
disent que ce sont des risques qui sont
aujourd'hui identifiés. Maintenant, il y
a une question, il y a la question de
les identifier. Il y a la question de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on fait et qu'est-ce
qu'on prépare et cetera. Il y a encore
trop souv d'abord il y a un énorme
problème de moyens aujourd'hui puisque
malheureusement on a plusieurs additions
qui sont en train d'arriver en même
temps. On a l'addition de la lâcheté
politique, on en parlera peut-être tout
à l'heure, l'addition euh de toute cette
délinquence qui est liée à des questions
notamment mais pas que migratoire. On en
parlera peut-être aussi tout à l'heure.
Pas que pas que
pas que. Non mais je dis notamment mais
pas que. On peut repasser la on peut
faire une vare si vous voulez pour voir.
Je viens de dire notamment mais pas que.
Euh et euh on a l'addition budgétaire,
c'est-à-dire qu'on va vers les moments
des moments sans doute critiques
avec moins de moyens qu'on en a jamais
eu, ce qui est pas de bol.
Et des forces de l'ordre fatigué
et des forces de l'ordre euh qui sont
euh évidemment euh fatiguées. Mais tout
de même la question, est-ce qu'on en a
est-ce que les gens en ont conscience ?
Je je suis plutôt rassuré. Par exemple,
j'ai été la semaine dernière passé 3
jours dans le cadre de de mon contrat de
réserviste opérationnel euh au centre de
de formation des forces de gendarmerie à
Saint-Astier
et euh
j'ai vu là-bas des cadres euh d'avoir
des mecs super et complètement conscient
des enjeux des mois et des années à
venir en terme en terme opérationnel, en
terme de besoins matériels et cetera.
C'était c'était très rassurant. sans
sortir de ta réserve ou de leur réserve
ou
psychologiquement parlant, ils le vivent
comment ? Parce que quand tu es en
première ligne, que tu es exposé au
manque de moyens, que tu te retrouves à
gérer des criminels qui sont relâchés au
bout de la 15e fois et que tu les
retrouves encore en train de [__] la
zizanie,
psychologiquement, ils sont dans quel
état ? C'est c'est pas c'est je vais
Toi, tu es dans quel état à anticiper
tout ça et à voir le pays partir en
quenouille ? Moi ça me rend malade,
c'est le sens de tout mon engagement.
Ah, c'est peut-être la question la plus
importante de ce soir pour moi, c'est
que je suis dans une logique où ça
aurait été assez simple la cinquantaine
bien dépassée
avec
Fais pas ton âge, hein.
Là, j'ai 57. Mais ce que je vais te
dire, c'est quelque chose qui date
d'avant, de il y a quelques années.
C'était le plus simple, ça aurait été de
bah de profiter de la vie.
J'ai j'avais eu j'ai eu une notoriété
professionnelle, j'ai beaucoup
travaillé. Maintenant, je suis dans la
phase assez confortable où je suis
reconnu professionnellement. Donc, le
besoin de reconnaissance est comblé. Je
gagne correctement ma vie.
Combien tu gagnes
aujourd'hui ? 220000 € par an.
Fiscalisé ou pas fiscalisé ?
Avant fiscalisation.
Après beaucoup moins.
Mais si j'avais fait du droit fiscal ou
de droits des affaires, tu peux rajouter
un zéro. Mais je suis très heureux dans
dans ce que je fais. Je j'ai une
formidable équipe, ce qui fait que je
travaille moins les weekend. Euh j'ai
une maison à la campagne, on dira pas
où, mais où je suis très heureux
d'aller. Je je je
Les chien adore aller chez toi. C'est
con. J'ai franchement euh j'ai C'est
cool quoi. Je pourrais profiter profiter
des des des je sais pas 15 20 30
un vrai patriote.
Ah ouais. Ah ouais. Mais c'est justement
pour ça, c'est que ça me rend malade. Et
donc, j'ai fait le choix de renforcer le
le centre de réflexion sur la sécurité
intérieure. On est vraiment en train de
de c'est c'est devenu une vraie machine
de guerre. On a un maillage territorial,
on a des équipes en province. Je fais
des Ça fait 2 ans que je fais des
tournées de tr
psychologiquement parlant, toi quand tu
vois le le pays partir en pardonne-moi
l'expression mais partir en couille
en quenouille.
Ouais. s filoché dans tous les sens avec
Ouais, ça me donne
une classe politique qui qui raconte
n'importe nawak.
Ouais.
Qui qui ou a des lunettes roses ou on
robe le truc pour que ça tienne peu en
malant jusqu'aux prochaines élections.
On parle vrai là entre toi et moi
et il faut arrêter là, il faut voir les
choses en face. Quand on t'a reçu en
2016, on vous a traité de tous les noms
parce qu'on avait reçu l'avocat
d'extrême droite, le fou furieux des
flammes.
Précise que j'ai jamais été d'extrême
droite, on pourra en parler
tranquillement mais c'est c'est un truc
c'est un truc qui est important.
Oui, mais c'est important.
Là, l'histoire te donne raison à 100 %
psychologiquement parlant de voir cette
catatonie émotionnel, de voir les gens
figés comme des lapins dans les phares,
mis à part quelques forces de l'ordre
qui essaent de faire remonter que le
pays est une poudrière. Les facteurs
économiques que nous on on monitore
derrière sont au rouge écarlate.
Rouge écarlate. Je suis d'accord. Les
les phénomènes de guerre économique sont
rouges écarlates. Les phénomènes de
guerre sont rouges écarlates.
Et les capacités que l'Europe et la
France s'en sortent sans trop perdre de
plume, c'est au rouge écarlate.
H
toi, tu bosses dans la séc, du moins, tu
observes la SQ, tu es un lanceur
d'alerte sur les questions de sécurité
psychologiquement parlant. Quand tu
allumes ton poste de télé, quand tu
prends n'importe quel journal et que tu
vois, excuse-moi l'expression encore,
tous ces cons raconter n'importe quoi,
tu as envie de faire quoi ?
Mais c'est ce que je commençais à te
dire, ça fait 2 ans que je me balade
partout en France. Je vais faire des
réunions publiques, j'en fais deux,
trois par mois. Euh et euh à chaque
fois, il y a plein de gens qui viennent
me voir, des centaines de personnes, des
Français qui font plein de choses. Il y
a pas loin sans faut, il y a pas que des
forces de l'ordre, il y en a. Mais il y
a il y a il y a des patrons de TPE, il y
a des fonctionnaires, il y a des profs,
il y a des médecins, il y a des
infirmières, il y a la la des
agriculteurs, beaucoup la France, le
pays, la chair et le sang, tu vois. et
et des et des élus locaux
et tous ces gens qui sont, on va dire
sur un spectre de de sensibilité
politique qui va allez de la de la
gauche valse, tu vois, la gauche
républicaine qui se tient, la dernière
gauche qui se tient, non mais si il y a
quand même il y a quand même ça ça se
tient globalement. Bon, on n'est pas
d'accord sur tout, mais c'est quand même
on se tient sur les valeurs
fondamentales et cetera jusque à
l'électorate. Donc quand je vois tous
ces gens qui viennent me voir, qui me
parlent, qui me confient euh le leur
leur espérance, qui me demandent de
m'engager, qui qui sont prêts eux à à
qui sont désespérés, qui voient les
choses, il faut pas croire que les
Français ne voient pas les choses. C'est
à Paris qu'on voit pas que les gens
voient les choses parce qu'il y a pas
exactement la même chose.
cette ce cette espèce de de mélange pas
de désespoir parce que moi je suis pas
désespéré mais de de d'inquiétude et de
rage que j'ai mais ça la ça la ça la
catalyse le
Saint-Paul dit l'espérance ne déçoit
jamais
ça
hein
Saul
Saul quoi
Saint-Paul
oui oui Saule pardon
l'espérance
je vais te faire réviser tes cours de
catéchisme
l'espérance [rires] l'espérance ne
déçoit jamais. Moi, je suis porté par
l'espérance. C'est-à-dire que un, j'ai
compris qu'on allait dans le dur, mais
de le dur, c'est pas la fin. Tu vois, ce
qu'il faut, c'est comprendre qu'on va
avoir des épreuves mais qui ont déjà
commencé. En vrai, on est déjà dedans.
Et là, je pense qu'il va y avoir une
accélération. C'est le phénomène de
toboggan. Donc quand on a un moment du
toboggan où je pense que ça va
accélérer. Mais à partir du moment où tu
le sais et où plein de gens l'ont
compris et où les gens ont envie de
faire des choses, ont envie de soutenir
des des des gars et des navins qui ont
envie de faire des choses, mais tu peux
pas être désespéré. La France a déjà
traversé des épreuves dans sa vie.
Tu peux pas être désespéré. Regarde, je
me fais encore du diable. Vas-y.
À la campagne, bon, il y a un gars qui
rentre chez toi, tu lui mets un coup de
12 au gros sel
euh un commerçant qui se fait
régulièrement agresser, il se fait
piquer que derrière on chope jamais les
mecs, au bout de la 15e fois, il en
attrape un, ça se termine mal, il le
giffle.
Ah, la justice dit, "Tu as pas le droit
de le gifler." Ouais, mais là tu me on
pose des je comprends ce que tu dis,
mais tu me poses des questions,
je surjoue mais tu comprends.
Oui. Oui, mais tu me poses des questions
sur combien ça va mal sur des questions
sur la conjoncture actuelle. Mais on est
d'accord, je te parle de toboggan et
d'accélération.
Où est-ce qu'on va là-dessus ?
On va si tu veux
à quelle vitesse, quel impact, quelle
inertie ?
Alors ça c'est c'est
question compliquée. Par définition, un
je sais pas maintenant. Je vois les
facteurs, je vois les je vois l'essence
et je vois plusieurs étincelles
possibles. D'accord ? L'essence, c'est
l'ensemble des fractures françaises.
C'est une société fracturée
économiquement, socialement,
culturellement ethniquement. Ça fait
beaucoup de M
religieusement.
Oui, mais je le mets dans le culturel,
tu as raison. Mais je le mets dans le
culturellement.
Ensuite sur les étincelles,
l'effondrement de l'autorité de l'État,
l'effondrement des moyens de l'État et
qu'on voit très très bien ce ce
fusé comme une mèche parce que
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui représentent
l'État, même même indirectement
maintenant ils se font insulter,
agresser, péter la gueule. Ça a été les
policiers et les gendarmes, ensuite ça a
été les services de secours, les
pompiers, le SAMU et cetera. Ensuite,
c'était les élus,
et et les les bien sûr les surveillants
de prison. Euh et euh et ensuite c'est
les profs dans les écoles, euh les
médecins, les infirmières dans les
hôpitaux, euh les les les éboueurs,
enfin tout ce que je veux dire, c'est
que tous les gens qui ont une fonction,
les tiens, les gens qui les gens qui
posent les gens qui sont dans les
services publics, Enedis, CDF, la SNCF,
tout ça, c'est des gens qui sont exposés
du fait que ils sont à qui sont en
uniforme et qui sont assimilés dans la
tête des connards à l'État Et moi, le
choc d'autorité que je prône, c'est
précisément le fait d'inverser la
tendance, c'est-à-dire de que l'État se
réapproprie l'usage légitime de la force
qui est la base du pacte social, hein.
C'est-à-dire que le le pacte social,
c'est on a une organisation juridique,
sociale et donc politique au terme de
laquelle le citoyen renonce à l'usage de
la force. en contrepartie
du fait que l'État assure sa protection
et pour se faire le citoyen paye des
impôts et je peux ajouter qu'il en paye
beaucoup. Donc le truc aujourd'hui c'est
que ce qui est la base du pacte social,
c'est pas une question de droite ou de
gauche he ça c'est très très important
de bien le comprendre. C'est la base du
pacte social
dans queles que soient les sociétés. La
la sécurité c'est un besoin primaire de
l'être humain. C'est la base de la
pyramide de Maslot. Donc on est dans une
logique qui est de bon sens et qui que
connaissent toutes les sociétés, queles
que soient les cultures et queles que
soient euh le moment de l'histoire.
C'est un principe de base de l'histoire
de l'humanité. Donc euh à partir euh de
là, il faut que que l'État se
réapproprie l'usage de la force
légitime. Pour le dire court, il faut
que la peur change de camp. Donc il faut
que les que les forces se remettent en
harmonie. Les forces du ministère de
l'intérieur, policeie et la force
judiciaire. Donc tout ça doit marcher
euh d'un même pas avec les politiques
garde des saut ministres de l'intérieur,
les haut fonctionnaires, les préfets
pour le ministre de l'intérieur, les
procureurs pour le ministre de la
justice et il faut que tout ça fasse une
chaîne cohérente et aujourd'hui
malheureusement ça n'est pas le cas.
Tu chiffres ça à combien ?
À combien quoi
d'euros 2 millions d'euros 2 milliards
d'euros ? Quand tu vois là le budget de
la justice
ou
budget
je vais répondre différemment.
Non je voudrais Enos tu as chiffré tu as
pas chiffré. Si tu as pas chiffré tu me
dis j'ai pas chiffré. J'ai chiffré,
j'ai une estimation mais ça implique de
changer complètement les les priorités.
Combien de points de P
aujourd'hui ? Aujourd'hui, le social
c'est 10 fois plus que le régalien.
D'accord ? Le régalien en grande masse
c'est à peu près 80 milliards d'euros.
Le social c'est un peu moins de 800.
Tout ça à la grosse louche que tous les
fact checkers la fois qu'il nous envoie
50 analyses à la virgule près parce que
évidemment on va pas tomber pile
là-dessus. Mais ce qui est très
important quand tu parles de de
d'évolution politique profonde, c'est
euh les grandes masses. Tu Mais mais la
principale truc qui manque, ça coûte
rien, c'est le courage.
C'est le courage politique. Aujourd'hui,
c'est
ce que disait Chirac
aujourd'hui. Ah bah, il a dit beaucoup
de choses mais
ouais. Avec les cerveaux et euh et les
couilles.
Ouais. Ouais. Ou oui. Ah bah oui, c'est
que
tu es
hein.
Tu es
Ah ben je suis donneur. C'est [rires]
bon, j'ai ce qu'il faut. Mais le Mais
mais c'est marrant,
toi tu es pas ministre. Mais ah bah ça
c'est pas au moi qu'il faut poser la
question, mais un mec comme moi
ministre, ça a failli arriver plusieurs
fois mais un type comme moi ministre moi
je suis prêt he c'estàd que j'ai fait le
alors tous ceux qui nous regardent et
qui disent alors je tiens on va faire un
truc quand même marrant pourquoi il est
pas ministre alors là il y a des gars
qui regardent ouais ça y est il est
comme les autres il veut aller à la
gamelle et cetera donc je précise tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure tu m'as demandé
combien je gagnais j'ai répondu si je
vais à la gamelle ça veut dire que
j'abandonne en vrai la gamelle pour
aller
à la gamelle vide parce que un ministre
ça gagne 9000 9500 € par mois. Donc par
rapport à ce que je gagne comme avocat,
ça ça n'a rien à voir. Il faut que les
gens comprennent que il y a des il y a
bien un certain nombre de personnes qui
par patriotisme sont prêts à faire de la
politique par
dans une logique désintéressée et
presque sacrificielle. peut-être faire
attention au grands mots qu'on emploie,
mais quand même, il y a de ça. Euh
aujourd'hui, moi je suis dans dans dans
cette logique et je suis loin d'être le
seul et je rencontre notamment
parmi les élus locaux beaucoup de gens
qui qui sont dans dans cette même
logique. Mais euh toute la la
difficulté, c'est que les gens qui font
de la politique professionnelle, donc
c'est le métier, il en fait ils servent
pas à faire autre chose. Donc quand il
voit arriver des personnalités de la
société civile qui ont la réputation
d'être compétence dans d'être compétente
dans leur domaine, ils ont une tendance
à s'en méfier. Alors le grand argument
c'est de dire pour ostraciser de dire
"Ouais mais le mec il a aucune
expérience de de l'État, il sait pas, il
a jamais été élu, il sait pas, il a
jamais machin et cetera". Bah c'est un
c'est un sujet à débattre. Ça veut pas
dire qu'ensuite ensuite c'est une
question d'équipe. Moi je crois beaucoup
aux équipes. Euh j'ai été j'ai j'ai créé
un cabinet d'avocat, donc je dirige une
équipe. Euh je bon CRSI je dirige une
équipe. J'ai été capitaine au foot
pendant pendant 15 ans. Euh j'ai été
sergent dans les paras et et donc je je
sais ce que c'est que de travailler en
équipe. Je ne travaille qu'en équipe.
Donc quand je quand je parle et que je
dis je à aucun moment je ne pense à moi
tout seul. Ça n'aurait évidemment
absolument aucun sens. Et on parlait de
courage tout à l'heure aujourd'hui.
Sauté nuit. Tu as sauté de nuit ?
Ouais.
En commandé ou pas en commandé ?
Ah non, pas en commandé, en automatique.
Sincèrement, pour ceux qui nous
regardent, je vais être honnête, j'étais
moyennement fier avec en plus j'ai tiens
j'ai eu un incident. Non, attends, j'ai
eu un incident une fois, on fait une
petite parenthèse quand même. J'ai un
saut à Pamier donc c'était dans mon
stage pour être sergent. Euh moi,
j'étais au 6e régiment parachutiste
d'infanterie de marine et on avait un
stage divisionnaire pour les trois
régiments d'infanterie où il y avait des
appelés de parachutistes pour être
sergent. Et moi c'est tombé à Pamier.
Pamier c'est dans Ariège. Donc dans les
ça caille c'était janvier février. On a
eu froid mais froid et on a fait un saut
de nuit après 2 jours sur le terrain
sans dormir. Et j'ai dû faire une
connerie en méquipant et donc on saute
bas tu vois. On saute je sais pas 250
300.
Tu es sûr 300 600 ?
Ah non non. Le saut le le saut le saut
le le sa le saut PM para il était à 400
et le le saut régiment opérationnel en
temps de paix il était à 250. Et le saut
en temps de guerre, il est en dessous de
200. Donc mais 250 ça va vite avec la
gaine. Et donc on sort de l'avion et il
fait encore nuit donc on voit rien. La
gaine du parachute.
Oui la gaine on sort la gaine c'est ce
que tu as dans les devant les jambes où
tu as ton sac avec l'arme. Et il faut ce
qu'on appelle larguer la gaine et tirer
donc sur une poignée une fois que tu as
sorti tu es sorti de l'avion le
parachute s ouvert et tu tu tires sur ta
poignée pour que la gaine reste pas sur
tes jambes parce que si elle reste sur
tes jambes tu te pètes tu peux te péter
les jambes. Et là je tire sur ma gaine
et ma gaine se détache pas. Donc, j'ai
dû faire une connerie en m'équipant et
comme les cadres étaient crevés aussi,
je pense que l'inspection a été un peu
moyenne et je et je vois pas où est le
sol et tout à coup, je me dis [__] je
vais me péter les jambes. Et là, j'ai
fait un truc de réflexe qui m'est venu,
c'est que je me suis dit, il faut que je
prenne le vent. Je fais d'habitude on va
contre le vent pour freiner. Et là, je
me dis, faut que je prenne le vent.
Comme ça, je vais tomber de côté et je
vais pouvoir faire un roulé boul avec ma
gaine sans que mes jambes me prennent.
Voilà, c'est ce que j'ai fait. Je me
suis fait très très mal aux fesses,
moyennement mal au genou, un peu mal aux
chilles, mais tout a tenu. Voilà, c'est
mon saut de nuit. Voilà, c'est pas le
truc dont je suis le plus fier mais je
m'en suis sorti.
On revient.
Ouais.
Les politiques
du coup. Ouais. Le courage plus que
l'argent, le courage. Ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui à droit constant, à droit
constant. La semaine prochaine, demain
matin, on peut décider que on va arrêter
de se faire marcher dessus par la
racaille. On peut décider que on va
demander l'incarcération de tous les
gens qui portent la main sur quiconque
est chargé d'une mission de service
public. Il y a pas de presse en prison.
Les magistrats, attends, les magistrats
sont indépendants, mais les parquets
doivent appliquer les circulaires de
politique pénale. Donc déjà, si on donne
le signal de l'impulsion politique,
je dis pas que tout le monde va que ça
va suivre comme un seolo mais ça va
donner ça va redonner de l'énergie, de
l'espoir. Si les gens voient, entendent
les discours mais pour la première fois
voi que les discours commencent à être
appliqués suivis des faits, mais ça va
galvaniser tout le monde. Tu sais très
bien que les que les que les dynamiques
humaines, elles sont avant tout morales.
Les dynamiques humaines, c'est une
question de gnac. C'est une question d'y
croire. Si plus personne n'y croit parce
qu'ils savent que le voisin n'y croit
plus, que le voisin n'y croit plus parce
que le chef n'y croit plus et parce que
au-dessus on les a abandonné. À tort ou
à raison si c'est l'idée dominante et
aujourd'hui c'est l'idée dominante.
Encore une fois, à tort ou à raison.
Parfois c'est excessif et parfois c'est
même injuste. Mais c'est comme ça.
Aujourd'hui, le voyou pense qu'il se
fera jamais guler et il pense que s'il
se fait, il lui arrivera rien de grave.
C'est pas toujours vrai. Parfois, il y a
des mecs qui prennent très cher au
tribunal mais pas assez et c'est pas
l'idée qu'on s'en fait. Donc le jour où
tu inverses cette dynamique et tu
réinsuffles de la force morale dans le
pays et que tu fais redresser la tête
aux policiers, aux gendarmes, aux
pompiers, aux élus locaux et cetera,
mais rien que ça, tu as pas dépensé 1 €
hein par rapport à tout à l'heure. Tu as
toujours pas dépensé 1 € et rien que ça,
ça commence à à à te remettre un peu
dans l'axe. Après, c'est certain, il va
falloir faire des réformes juridiques,
il va falloir faire des réformes
constitutionnelles à un moment, il va
falloir faire des réformes au niveau
européen. Et ça, tout ça, ça nécessite
d'avoir une majorité qui a un mandat
pour le faire qui lui donne une
légitimité. Donc ça c'est pas tout de
suite. Mais cette histoire de courage et
de force morale, ça peut être demain
matin.
On a le temps de faire toutes ces
réformes où la situation économique,
sociale et et géopolitique est tellement
dramatique.
C'est c'est tu sais c'est c'est pas
parce que le le
parce que tic tac tic tac on entend le
le bruit de l'horloge qui se rapproche
d'un d'un problème dont on sait pas très
bien quelle forme il va prendre mais
mais mais on sait qu'on va en avoir un.
C'est pas pour ça qu'il faut se poser le
cul sur la chaise et rien faire. C'est
il faut faire euh ce qu'on peut. Il faut
faire ce qu'on peut le plus vite
possible, le mieux possible et cetera.
Euh tu es jamais à l'abri que ça se
passe un peu moins mal que ce qu'on
avait craint.
Jamais à l'abri. Euh et puis bah tout ce
que tu as fait c'est plus à faire. Donc
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait énormément de
temps. C'est pour ça que je pense que le
principal
pardon le principal c'est la force
morale et le et et à partir de là bah tu
fais ce que tu peux. par dans l'ordre
des urgences et puis euh et puis tu
essayes d'avoir de de d'avoir un jour
une majorité absolue qui te permettent
une réforme constitutionnelle qui te
permettent de de remettre vraiment le le
pays dans l'axe.
Je vais te faire lire une page de ton
bouquin et et pendant que tu prends ton
verre d'eau, château la pompe 2025
ou
je vais te poser je vais te poser une
question qui n'a rien à voir. Ton beret
était noir, vert ou Bordeaux ?
Euh il était amarrante
amarrante ? Oui,
je te fais lire le chapitre
la première page du chapitre 5.
La première page du chapitre 5.
Je t'ai mis une corde.
OK.
En haut à droite.
Chapitre 5.
Le titre c'est pour un choc d'autorité.
C'est
on s'en fout du titre d'ec.
Pour l'ensemble des raisons qui ont été
abordées dans cet ouvrage à ce stade,
l'hypothèse d'une vague de violence
incontrôlée qui viendrait frapper la
France pendant plusieurs jours ou
semaines consécutives sans que l'État
parvienne à conserver la maîtrise est un
risque réel et désormais élevé. Il est
évoqué depuis plusieurs années lors de
mes discussions privées par tous les
acteurs sérieux de ces questions. Depuis
plusieurs mois, j'ai pu observer deux
évolutions convergantes. D'abord, chez
les professionnels, policiers,
gendarmes, militaires, pompiers et
cetera. L'hypothèse est maintenant
évoquée de façon beaucoup plus concrète
qu'avant, y compris désormais dans les
rangs très élevés de la hiérarchie.
Ensuite, lors des réunions publiques au
cours desquelles je rencontre un peu
partout nos compatriotes, il en est
systématiquement quelques-uns pour
aborder le sujet sans crainte de le
faire publiquement et sans susciter
d'opprobres particuliers parmi
l'assistance dans laquelle figurent des
élus locaux tout aussi inquiets que la
population.
Tu peux fermer le livre, le garder à
côté de toi parce que peut-être que je
te ferai lire une petite papage. Comment
ça s'appelle ce bouquin déjà ?
France, le choc ou la chute ?
Qui c'est qui a écrit ça déjà ?
Tibo de Montbria. Ça va alors ? Ça ?
Ah, c'est pas moi qui le vend, c'est
l'éditeur. 21 €.
Combien tu prends dessus ?
10 %.
10 %. Tu as eu des avoirs ?
Ouais.
Combien ?
12000.
Pas mal. Tu en as vendu combien ?
Pour l'instant, on n pas encore les
chiffres, c'est pas mal. Le dernier
point fait par l'éditeur, je sur les
ventes, alors c'est compliqué sur les
ventes librairies, je crois qu'on va
arriver aux 10000. C'estàd que c'est pas
les livres vendu grand public, c'est ce
que les libraires ont acheté et ensuite
le public les achète. Alors nous le
problème c'est que
alors allez-y vite parce que c'est pour
Noël ça.
Nous nous le problème c'est qu'on te
connaît depuis 2018 et que quand on l'a
lu, on avait ta voix dans la tête.
Ouais.
On s'est régalé même si on connaissait
déjà les chiffres, on a eu en fait ça
nous a permis de croiser nos propres
sources et comme on te fait confiance en
terme d'acquisition de renseignement, on
était très content de le lire pour
vérifier deux trois trucs.
Alors je précise une chose he puisque tu
parlais tout à l'heure des sources qui
doivent être rigoureuses et je suis
complètement d'accord. Il y a trois
sources dans ce livre. Ministère de
l'Intérieur, ministère de la justice,
Union européenne, ça c'est pour les
statistiques, les pourcentages et
cetera. Et j'ajoute des expériences
persos et des récits où là c'est
subjectif parce que c'est des choses
qu'on m'a raconté. Mais euh tout ce que
je tout ce qu'on m'a raconté corrobor ce
que donnent les statistiques.
Range-le à côté de ta petite cuisse
gauche ou à droite. Metsle.
Ouais. Hop.
Euh
je vais te reposer une question
maintenant sur si on ne fait rien ou si
on continue le rondrond quotidien de nos
politiciens.
Cette défaillance, cette démission ou
cette forfaiture, appelle ça comme tu
veux.
On va vers quoi ? On va vers
façon Amérique du Sud,
narcotrafic, mafia, corruption
politique.
On va vers une tier mondisation
dramatique. Tu tu vois la chose si rien
n'est fait tel que tes préconisations
sont alignées,
qu'est-ce qui il faut se préparer à quoi
? Il y a deux cas de figure si on fait
rien. Le premier c'est qu'on continue à
s'affaisser
et le deuxème c'est qu'on s'effondre.
L'affaissement peut virer à
l'effondrement. Encore une fois, c'est
une question d'étincelle. C'est une
question de Alors,
l'effondrement euh mets-moi des mots
dessus, ça ressemble à quoi ? Bah
les fond alors je vais répondre mais il
faut quand même comprendre que le sens
de mon engagement c'est quand même de
tout faire pour qu'il n'arrive pas.
C'est très très important. Je suis mais
ça ça mérite 2 secondes. Moi je suis pas
un décliniste au sens du gars euh qui
est qui tape comme dans Tintin euh c'est
l'île mystérieuse je crois où il y a le
prophète Philippulus qui tape sur le
gong en disant c'est la fin du monde, la
fin des temps et cetera. Moi je suis pas
du tout dans cette optique. Je suis dans
l'optique de dire ça va mal, il faut se
retrousser les manches et il faut faire
des choses. Je le redis parce que c'est
vraiment essentiel. Une fois qu'on a dit
ça ou quoi ? C'està-dire quelle est
l'alternative si personne ne fait rien ?
Bah on voit les
si on peut pas le financer
mais ça revient au même. Mais même si on
peut pas le financer he au risque de me
répéter le simple fait de changer
d'assumer un peu le le le l'application
de la loi républicaine par les forces de
l'ordre et le fonctionnement de la
justice déjà ça changerait un tout petit
peu les choses. Pas que un petit peu.
Mais j'en reviens à ta question. What if
? Si si on peut pas le ce qui va se
passer, c'est que la pénétration de la
culture mafieuse et de l'islamisme va
continuer. Elle elle se recouvre en
partie puisque immense majorité de la
grande criminalité organisée et
d'origine et de culture
araboom-musulmane.
Donc on va aller
C'est quoi ta source ?
Alors j'ai une anecdote que
Non mais je veux pas une anecdote, je
une source.
C'est un premier ministre. Ancien
premier ministre.
Mais mais carré cubique ou c'est un peu
de couloir ? Ah non, il m'a dit qu'il
avait fait faire une liste qu'il avait
demandé à ses services une liste des 100
familles les plus criminelles jeunes de
France et que elles avaient elles
étaient toutes d'origine
extraruropéenne.
Elle est elle est où la liste ?
Ah ça j'en sais rien. Il me l'a pas
montré.
Donc si quelqu'un m'appelle pour avoir
ta source, tu es capable de lui donner.
Si quelqu'un t'appelle pour avoir la
pour avoir la source, je je lui
répondrai que c'est un ancien premier
ministre qui me l'a dit. Voilà. Ensuite,
un ancien premier ministre de gauche.
Ouais. Ensuite, enagne,
l'ancien pr ministre de gauche. Ensuite
euh et benah, il y en a eu plusieurs
et les deux et ils étaient tous petits
donc comme ça je prends pas de risque.
Le ce qui est très intéressant sur le
parce que on va on va aller sur on va
crever un abscès là quand même 2
secondes parce que ça fait deux fois que
tu me fais que tu que tu me fais des
périphrases, ça te ressemble pas. Donc
on va on va y aller sur l'immigration,
sur la délinquence et l'immigration.
Toutes les states le montrent. Toutes
les stats montrent une très large
surreprésentation délinquence
immigration. Dans le livre, il y a deux
pages où il y a toutes les statistiques.
D'accord ? Ministère de l'intérieur,
ministère de la justice et Union
européenne. Mais
c'est parce que tu tu sais que je suis
chiant avec les sources.
Mais en plus, mais tu as raison, c'est
très important. C'est c'est pas une
question d'être chiant. Tu d'abord tu
c'est le respect qu'on doit à ceux qui
nous regardent et et ensuite c'est parce
qu'il faut dépassionner le sujet.
Moi, je suis ça va peut-être surprendre
ceux qui me connaissaient pas, mais je
pense que l'immigration c'est un sujet
qu'on prend mal. On le prend on le prend
en passionnel. Il y en a qui te disent
que c'est une chance pour la France, il
y en a qui te disent que c'est pas une
chance pour la France. Moi, je pose
simplement la question. Je dis pourquoi
ne considère-t-on pas cette question
comme étant simplement ce qu'elle est ?
C'est-à-dire une question de
souveraineté. Un pays a parfaitement le
droit de décider qui rentre, comment, à
quelles conditions, pour combien de
temps euh et ensuite qui peut et dans
quelles conditions acquérir la
nationalité. C'est un truc de base, ça
pose zéro problème dans la plupart des
pays du monde. Donc déjà, il faut donc
du coup, il faut se poser les questions.
Est-ce que notre pays et nos
compatriotes, puisqu'un gouvernement est
là pour protéger ses concitoyens, pas le
monde entier, euh a un intérêt ou non
sur le plan culturel, sur le plan
social, sur le plan sécuritaire, sur le
plan financier à à l'immigration. Et
aujourd'hui, la réponse à toutes ces
questions, il se trouve que c'est non.
Mais ça veut pas dire que il faut
arrêter 100 % de l'immigration, renvoyer
tous les immigrés et que les immigrés
sont responsables de tout parce que ça
c'est pas vrai. Et on mélange tout.
Voilà. Donc il faut être très calme, il
faut regarder les statistiques, il faut
en tirer un certain nombre de
conséquences. Par exemple, je dis moi il
y en a une que je sors toujours parce
que il y a beaucoup de gens qui ne la
connaissent pas, c'est qu'on te dit
toujours s'il y a moins d'immigration,
il y a plus personne dans les restos, il
y a plus personne pour ramasser les
poubelles et il y a plus personne pour
conduire les transports en commun.
J'exagère à peine. Mais sauf que c'est
pas vrai. L'immigration de travail,
c'est 15 %. C'est 15 %. Donc OK, on
garde les 15 % mais le reste qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? Est-ce qu'il y a une par
exemple le regroupement familial ? Ça
c'est des vrais sujets. Donc premier
premièrement, il faut raisonner de façon
avec la tête froide.
Quelle était ma question maître ?
La question c'était les statistiques sur
la question c'est si on fait rien
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Ah oui, mais
moi j'ai fait une petite parenthèse sur
l'immigration parce que c'est quand
même j'avais envie de la faire parce
qu'il faut éclaircir le sujet et juste
pour finir sur délinquence et
immigration parce que tu m'as demandé
sur la liste machin la liste c'était une
anecdote la réalité et je cite dans mon
bouquin avec ouvrez les guillemets je
mets les noms le préfet de police de
Paris qui se trouvait être Laurent Lunis
qui est aujourd'hui ministre de
l'intérieur et la préfète de la région
au Grenalpe qui chacun à la place qui
était la leure début 2025 expliqu
expliquait l'explosion de la place des
étrangers dans les violences, dans les
transports par exemple. Et puis il y a
50 autres statistiques dans le livre qui
qui tous ceux qui sont sur ce sujet ont
besoin d'avoir des billes. C'est
extrêmement simple.
Il faut pas lire il faut pas lire ce
bouquin juste avant le 24 décembre.
Non, il faut l'offrir avant le 24.
Faut Oui, on peut l'offrir avant le 24
décembre mais je vous déconseille de le
lire avant le 24 décembre. Attends,
juste dire une chose aux gens quand
même, c'est que toute la dernière partie
c'est l'espérance hein. C'est- qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ? Oui et puis même
c'est même un message quasi spirituel
c'est de d'un engagement au combat pour
notre pays pour la France la France
millénaire les racines enfin tout ça est
également abordé
tu parles de l'honneur de l'engagement
oui
tu es prêt à aller à la guerre avec les
Russes là contre les Russes tu es prêt à
aller te cartonner avec Sergey Popov
prier qui va te mettre une race parce
que tu as 3 jours de cartouche
Alors
d'abord dis-moi
D'abord la guerre,
ouais,
je me suis préparé à aller la faire
pendant la guerre du golf puisque j'ai
été formé, entraîné et que on nous
disait "Tu as eu des vaccins ?
Oui, bien sûr."
Celui qui te font faire du pipi rouge
là,
j'ai tout eu. Et et en plus à l'époque,
on te mettait tes vaccins et après tu
prenais une claque au cul, tu allais
faire 20 km pour purger, pour faire
circuler le sang, il disait. Donc ouais,
j'ai eu tout ça. Mais surtout euh et
sérieusement euh moi je suis de août 90
et euh pardon octobre 90 août 90 c'est
l'invasion du CIT. Et quand je suis
arrivé en régiment, on nous a dit "Vous
êtes force d'action rapide, vous avez
signé les volontariats qui vont bien et
cetera, préparez-vous pour la guerre."
et et j'ai pensé et on nous a expliqué
que la division d'Agu qui était à
l'époque la division qui était projetée
euh d'abord allait avoir ils avaient
anticipé 4000 morts sur 12000 euh donc
ce qui fait quand même un/ers et que
nous étions nous forces d'action rapide
y compris les appelés par la magie de ce
que nous avions signé en volontariat
nous n'étions plus vraiment des appelés
et que c'est nous qui irions euh en
remplacement. Donc pourquoi je prends le
temps de dire ça ? que la question
mentale de se dire je vais aller à la
guerre, c'est un sujet que j'ai que j'ai
déjà abordé avec moi-même. Euh, j'ai
énormément de chance de pas y être allé.
Je fais pas le cake, je fais pas le
fanfaron. Tous les gens que je connais
qui sont allés à la guerre euh disent à
quel point c'est une expérience dont on
peut se passer. Je je me trompe pas sur
sur ce sujet. Ça n'empêche pas mon
patriotisme, mon engagement et cetera.
Maintenant euh 2e temps sur perso hein,
tu m'as dit de toi aujourd'hui j'ai je
les gens ont bien compris je crois
maintenant 57 ans.
Oh là là ! Et en Ukraine, ils vont
jusqu'à 63 ans hein.
Et ben justement, c'est ce que j'allais
te dire. En Ukraine ça va jusqu'à début
de la soixantaine. Mais simplement ce
que j'allais juste dire c'est qu'à 57,
c'est quand même plus la même qu'à 20 en
terme physique, en terme de fatigue, la
douleur ceci, la résistance physique et
cetera. Donc très sincèrement, je ne
souhaite pas à notre population et en
particulier aux gens plus âgés, mais à
tout le monde hein, parce que pour les
momes, c'est pas plus drôle, d'être
contraint de faire la guerre. Mais il y
a un énorme mais c'est que un pays ne
peut rester libre, ne peut rester maître
de son destin que si sa population est
prête à l'engagement au sens le plus
large. Pas forcément l'engagement avec
un fusil mais à l'engagement et autant
difficile. S'il y a un effondrement
moral euh on aura perdu avant même que
il y ait que qu'il y ait le le moindre
affrontement. Moi, je souhaite vraiment
qu'il n'y en ait pas.
Mais toujours à tout moment de ma vie, y
compris dans les pour les pour les trucs
qui sont plus perso, les islamistes qui
me menacent, qui sont venus me enfin il
y a quand même eu des situations asas
quelques chapeaux qui sont venus avec
toi. Il y a eu il y a eu des moments
tendus. Euh il y en a toujours donc
c'est des questions en plus à titre
perso que que qui qui sont dans dans ma
vie hein. La la l'hypothèse de la
violence elle est permanente. Donc euh
ce que ce que je veux dire c'est que on
est on est mais c'est comme ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur le rapport à
la délinquence pour l'état, la police,
la gendarmerie. Il faut il il faut que
la peur change de camp. Si tu montres
C'est pour ça que tu as appelé ton chien
Bénéli.
Mon chien Bénéelli ou Ouais est bien
dressé. Mon chien Bené
éduqué
hein. Il est bien éduqué pardon. Il est
bien il est bien éduqué mais
il dit il demande tes papi avant.
Ouais. Pas sûr.
Il dit "S'il te plaît". S'il vous plaît.
Oui, il dit s'il te plaît. Mais euh
blague à part euh le la question c'est
la la c'est la question de la
détermination. Si tu si tu baisses les
yeux en premier, tu es foutu. Les gens
et on confond tout dans le débat public
comme on est en paix depuis 80 ans, ce
qui est une forme de bénédiction. Mais
il y a il y a la malédiction associée,
c'est que du coup le pays entier et les
gens sauf ceux dont c'est le métier
ignore absolument tout de ce que c'est
que la nécessité de de même d'une
cohésion. On est devenu un pays
complètement individualiste,
consumériste. Et donc les gens, ils sont
dans la jouissance immédiate. En plus,
il y a toutes les pertes de compétences
avec les écrans et cetera, ce qui d'un
point de vue en terme militaire et
cetera est encore un sujet. Euh donc
tout tout ça fait que on a une une
succession de crise, un empilement de
crise intérieur, peut-être maintenant
euh extérieur, j'espère pas, à un moment
où on n' jamais été aussi peu préparé
pour les affronter et aussi peu perd et
aussi et autant perdu. Juste pour finir,
parce que euh le mot guerre, il a été
mis à toutes les sauces par le président
de la République. Il y a eu la guerre
contre le vac contre le vaccin, laus, la
guerre contre le Covid, il y a eu la la
guerre contre il y a eu la guerre contre
tout. Et maintenant qu'il y a un risque
de vraie guerre, on emploie quel mot ?
Apocalypse.
J'espère que non.
Revenons à la question que tu as pas que
tu as pas répondu ou tu as pas voulu
répondre. Si on fait rien, ça va se
matérialiser comment ? Ça va ressembler
à quoi ? Ça va ressembler à l'exunion
soviétique qui s'est cassé la figure et
il faudra s'occuper d'une petite milice
locale, il faudra dorloter le flic qui
dort dans ta cité parce que comme il est
un peu armé qui sait regarder les armes,
il peut te maintenir la sécurité. Donc
il faudra lui améliorer un peu son
quotidien avec un bout de poulet. Euh ça
va ressembler à quoi ? Des enlèvements
comme en Amérique du Sud. Ah c'est déjà
lequ en France déjà d'ailleurs.
Ouais c'est le cas en France. Mais
justement j'ai été un des premiers à
dire dans le débat public qu'il y avait
une sud-américanisation depuis 2 3 ans,
4 ans. Ensuite Bruno Retillot, il a pris
mexicanisation et cetera, mais l'idée
est la même. C'est quoi cette idée ? Au
début tout à l'heure, je disais qu'il y
avait deux grandes forces qui prenaient
la place d'un état défaillant. C'est la
grande criminalité organisée et
l'islamisme. La grande criminalité
organisée.
Tu parles pas d'école blanc là ?
Ah ben parce que si parce que dans le la
grande communauté organisée derrière il
y a le blanchiment. C'estàd que tu as
tout tuas tu as tout ce qui suit.
J'allais y venir. Tu es impatient hein.
Mais je vais y venir. C'est
parce que tu me chauffes depuis tout à
l'heure là. Je suis tout moustillé.
Attends attends. Ouais ouais ça le le
truc qui est très important à
comprendre. Je fais un focus 2 secondes
sur les conséquences de la grande
criminalité organisée parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui se disent même si
maintenant ça flingue dans tous les sens
he il y a 173 villes en 20243
villes où il y a eu des tirs à l'arme de
guerre sur fond de grande criminalité
organisée ou au moins au pistolet donc
oh c'était pour fêter un mariage c'est
pas grave
c'était sauf qu'au lieu d'être vers le
haut c'était c'était à l'horizontal
soyez en passant je fais une parenthès
les gens oublient la physique he c'est
que quand tu tires vers le haut il y a
toujours un moment où le projectile
redescend je referme la parenthès C'est
de la physique qui ferait peut-être pas
ça.
C'est vrai. Le mieux étant quand même de
s'abstenir. La criminalité organisée,
elle se développe euh par un du fait de
la défaillance de l'État, 2 par
l'hyperviolence,
3 par la corruption et là on en arrive
au col blanc. Aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui
la fin 2025, qu'est-ce qu'on voit ? Tu
as pas oublié un facteur là ?
Lequel ?
Le malette de la population. Oui, mais
parce que tout ça c'est ce qui rend
impossible le le mal de la population,
j'allais y venir, c'est la consommation
de stupe. Très très important. Et oui,
mais si. Et attends, attends, attends,
je me fais la voquer du diable.
Ouais.
Pourquoi les gens ils consomment des
stupes ? Parce que leur vie est
tellement pourrie, ils sont tellement
sous pression qu'ils sont obligés de
résister. Donc ils prennent des petites
pilules,
ils prennent des petits cheats, ils
prennent du petit machin, du petit bitin
parce que ils sont tellement érintés,
ils sont tellement mal chez eux. Et
après c'est un cercle vicieux, ils sont
camés. C'est pour ça que dans
Tu es d'accord avec moi ou tu es pas
d'accord avec moi ?
Non mais je suis d'accord avec toi mais
ça nécessite une réponse plus globale.
Mais je vais aller direct sur la fin de
de de ce que tu viens de dire.
Pourquoi est-ce que je disais tout à
l'heure que dans mon livre, il y a un
motif, j'espère en tout cas ce que je
porte c'est vraiment l'espérance, c'est
que il faut en fait il faut qu'on change
tout dans cette société et et il faut
que donner envie aux gens de nouveau de
former une société commune. Et pour ça,
il faut avoir des objectifs, faut avoir
des rêves, des rêves ensemble. Faut
rêver, faut faut rêver de de retrouver
le plaisir d'une vie commune, d'avoir la
même vision des choses et toi ?
Ouais, je suis cat.
Tu connais le relancement de
Saint-Pierre ?
Non. Vas-y.
Moi, je sortirai de ce monde où l'action
n'est pas sœur du rêve.
Ouais.
Bah, il a quand même fait quelques
accomplissements avant d'en sortir.
Mais il faut rêver. Il faut du rêve.
Alors, il faut de la transcendance. Moi,
je suis revenu. Alors, je sais pas si
là, tu as trois questions en une, donc
je sais pas à laquelle je réponds, je
réponds toujours à la dernière. Euh moi,
ma foi est revenue depuis 3 ans. C'est
marrant, j'étais câau éduqué quand
j'étais gamin.
À cause de la peur,
non, à cause du sentiment de du à cause
de la prise de conscience de ce qu'on
risquit de perdre.
Donc la peur,
oui, mais ça m'a pas fait peur.
C'est la prise de conscience de ce qu'on
risquait de perdre. Je sais pas comment
te dire. Je comprends ton idée quand tu
dis on peut résumer par peur la crainte
mais pas la peur. La peur la peur c'est
dans les tripes. La peur et j'ai déjà eu
peur dans ma vie. Pas pas la vraie peur
c'est un truc qui
tu as été menacé tu as été
Oui oui. J'ai voilà donc bon mais mais
les mais mais c'est la crainte. La
crainte c'est c'est plus diffus. C'est
c'est ça te conduit à t'engager. La peur
tu réagis la la crainte tu t'organises.
Tu fais des choses.
Tu pries.
Oui.
Tous les
Tu pries qui ?
Tous les jours
qui
euh le Christ. La Vierge Marie tombe de
sein tous les jours et ça m'apporte
énormément d'apaisement et je suis très
Michel un peu
hein
Michel
bah attends c'est la base. Saint-Michel
lutte contre le dragon le patron des
parachutistes et cetera. Euh très
important puisqu'on aborde ce sujet. Je
je crois profondément à la phrase
"Aide-toi le ciel t'aidera."
C'est-à-dire que moi d'abord ma foi, tu
vois, tu me poses la question, je te
réponds mais c'est jamais quelque chose
que je mets en avant.
C'est quelque chose qui est perso, c'est
quelque chose qui me donne une force,
tu me touche là,
une force fondamentale parce que je moi
je suis complètement aligné. C'estàd que
je je suis je je je sais qui je suis, je
sais pourquoi je suis dans cet
engagement, ce qui est un combat. Je
sais qu'il peut mal se terminer, mais
c'est des choses que j'accepte parce que
je je me sens bien et donc je renoncerai
pas à tout ce que je porte puisque je je
le sentiment de faire quelque chose qui
me correspond et qui correspond, je
l'espère, à au bien commun. Donc ça ça
me donne la force. Mais par contre, je
suis pas dans une logique de croisade et
d'évangélisation, tu vois. Je suis pour
que les gens qui vivent en France euh
qui soient euh musulmans, qui soient
juifs, qui soient protestants, qui soit
catholique et cetera, puisse avoir la
liberté absolue
de vivre leur foi à deux conditions. La
première, c'est de respecter la loi de
la République quand même. Et la
deuxième, c'est de pas faire chier, ce
qui est pas une condition très
juridique, mais ce qui permet de résumer
et qui est de dire quand même que en
France, nous sommes un pays
aux racines greco-latines et de
tradition judéo-chrétienne. C'est comme
ça, c'est notre histoire et que en
France, on a un mode de vie en plus de
nos lois, on a un mode de vie et ce mode
de vie doit aussi être préservé. Et donc
là, c'est très très clair. Soit tu
acceptes ce mode de vie et tu vis euh en
ici en en faisant ce que tu veux le soir
euh euh chez toi, le vendredi soir, le
samedi que ça tu fais ce que tu veux.
Mais par contre, si tu commences à dire
"Vas-y, excuse-moi, moi je mange pas ça.
Moi, les femmes, elles sont comme si,
moi je prends pas d'alcool. Moi,
j'arrête le match à 18h12 parce que
c'est la rupture du jeune. Alors même
que par ailleurs, le Coran permet de de
de de gérer le Ramadan différemment,
mais tu fais semblant de pas le savoir
et cetera. Là, tu commences à rentrer
dans une logique qui est celle que je
combats. Voilà. Donc c'est exactement
ça. Mais en tout cas ma ma foi, puisque
c'était la question euh ça n'est pas
quelque chose pour lesquel je fais du
prosélitisme, mais c'est quelque chose
qui renforce mon patriotisme et qui me
donne euh une force euh aujourd'hui, une
force absolue, une détermination
absolue.
Ta femme, elle dit quoi quand tu dis que
tu es dans une attitude sacrificielle,
que tu es prêt à risquer ta vie pour le
pays ? J'en ai beaucoup parlé avec elle
et ma femme, elle m'a dit quelque chose
qui est qui m'a bouleversé et qui me
bouleverse encore, c'est que elle me dit
qu'elle pense qu'elle considère que
l'une de ses principales missions de
vie,
c'est d'être à mes côtés pour ça.
Je peux pas te dire mieux. C'est
Tu as des enfants ?
Ouais. Quel âge ?
Ça va ? De 22 à 31. Puile poil pour
notre chef d'étatmajor. Ouais. Tu as
pris les déclarations du chef
d'étatmajor toi qui connaît les
militaire, qui connaît les forces
d'action rapide ou moins rapide, tu as
pris ça comment en tant que père ?
En tant que père, ça fait longtemps que
j'ai intégré ces problématiques, hein,
puisque de toute façon c'est ma propre
histoire. C'est la c'est des questions
que je me pose depuis que je suis ados,
que j'ai vécu, on en parlait tout à
l'heure, pendant la guerre du golf et
cetera. Donc euh bah quand tu vois tes
enfants qui deviennent adultes euh tu
vois toute cette espèce de boule de vie
qui porte et puis tu vois aussi tout ce
qui risque de venir sur leur chemin. Et
il y a il y a cette hypothèse qui qui
est pas la seule mais qui est qui est
une hypothèse bien sûr. C'est c'est
toujours je te dire le le quand quand je
regarde la situation. Tu me demandais
tout à l'heure quand tu regardes quand
tu regardes les journaux les machins toi
qui qui connaît les choses est-ce que tu
es pas désespéré ? Je te répondais que
je l'étais pas et les raisons pour
lesquelles j'étais pas mais je suis
lucide.
C'est pour mes enfants que que ça
c'est là le truc qui m'atteint, tu vois,
c'est que parfois je me dis mais c'est
ça ça dure jamais très longtemps, mais
parfois je me dis [__] euh il faut il
faut il faut il faut il faut se battre
de tout notre cœur pour pour que nos
enfants ne vivent pas de drame, que nos
enfants, tu sais, on a toujours envie
que nos enfants aient une vie meilleure
que nous. C'est c'est humain, c'est une
espèce de de de progression à tous
égards. Et là, on n'est pas sûr,
franchement, on n'est pas sûr du tout
même. Alors, on est encore jeune, hein,
parce que on est encore on peut encore
faire plein de choses. Donc, si ça se
passe mal, ça, on va le vivre aussi.
Mais l'engagement,
c'est vraiment pour éviter que ça se
passe mal. Et ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est qu'il y en a qui se
trompent dans l'analyse du truc. C'estàd
qu'il y a des gens qui pensent que parce
qu'on parle de ces sujets, on serait
dans une logique d'affrontement ou dans
une logique d'avoir envie par un espèce
de sentiment malsin que des choses comme
ça arrivent. Mais en fait pas du tout.
On a envie de tout sauf de ça. Et c'est
c'est ça le sens de de mon
Est-ce que tu réponds aux gens qui te
disent voilà tu es un prophète de
malheurement
une Cassandre qui souhaite que ces
prophéties soient autoréalisatrices.
C'est ce que je viens je viens de te
répondre. Je leur réponds que pas du
tout. Au contraire d'abord moi je suis
plus un prophète. J'ai été peut-être il
y a 10 ans mais aujourd'hui je me
prépare, je suis dans une forme d'action
et je me prépare à l'action
premièrement. Donc c'est quand même plus
du tout la même chose. Tu vois pas les
choses de la même chose. Tu vois pas les
choses de la même manière quand tu te
dis si demain je suis ministre de
l'intérieur comment je fais puisque il y
a déjà eu plusieurs c'est toi qui
parlais tout à l'heure. Donc je je te
permets de
ser un bon ministre à l'intérieur.
Mais ça dépend avec qui ? avec moi. Tu
signes. [rires]
J'ai j'ai le
j'ai l'ambassadeur Dirant qui me qui me
disait je dis c'est pas possible moi je
serai président de la République quand
vous serez ministre des affaires
étrangères.
Je je vais là
pour la blague. Si je suis si je suis
président de la République, je te prends
ministre de l'intérieur. Tu acceptes tu
acceptes pas.
Mais je je si c'est toi, j'accepte. Si
c'est toi, j'accepte vraisemblablement.
Mais il faut parler du périmètre, il
faut parler de de la latitude et cetera
parce que il y a rien de pire que d'être
pris comme caution. C'est un risque. Pas
comme je te prends pour toi
faire le ménage.
Toi toi toi, il y a pas de doute dans
l'hypothèse. Mais là là moi je te répond
dans la vraie vie. Dans la vraie vie, il
y a le risque d'être récupéré.
C'estàdire que on dise bah tiens, mon
brial, il s'entend bien, il connaît bien
le système, il est il est il a une bonne
image au sein de tous les services
régéliens. Je fais cours et je
caricature. Et donc on va le mettre
comme ça. Comme ça les mecs comme ça les
mecs ils sont tenus et cetera. Mais ça
moi j'ai pas envie. Mais toi si on
ministre parce que tu connais le
terrain, tu connais les stats, tu
connais.
Oui. Non non mais dans ce cas-là c'est
encore une fois la question c'est pas
est-ce que oui ou non je j'accepterai.
La question c'est avec qui et pour quoi
faire ? C'est c'est la seule question.
Donc
avec moi pour sauver le pays, tu signes
avec toi pour sauver le pays. Allez
allez. Tu me conseilles qui comme
ministre de la défense ?
J'ai pas envie de partir dans des dans
des name dropping dans la Je j'ai j'ai
quelques idées mais qui sont un peu qui
sont un peu disruptive.
Ah oui, une femme
peut-être.
On pense à la même.
Oh, je sais pas. Il y a plusieurs femmes
qui pourraient remplir le rôle mais il y
a aussi quelques hommes.
Ça joue. Euh on arrive à la fin bientôt
de notre interview parce que on a des
choses à faire toi comme moi ce soir.
Euh est-ce que tu as un sujet qu'on a
pas abordé ? tu souhaiterais aborder
avec nous ou est-ce que tu souhaiterais
nous lire un une page de ton livre ?
Moi ce que je voudrais dire
parce que moi j'ai subi tout ton livre
avec ta voix dans la tête. Ce que je
voudrais dire aux gens qui nous
regardent,
c'est pas fini, juste un sujet, un sujet
que tu souhaiterais aborder.
Ouais. C'est la façon dont il faut
tendre la main notamment aux enfants de
l'immigration qui sont en France et qui
sont pris entre le marteau et l'enclume.
Voilà, ça c'est un vrai sujet sur lequel
on m'attend pas forcément, sur auquel
j'ai consacré plusieurs pages, c'est que
il faut il faut encore une fois, il y en
a qui caricatur ma logique, mais c'est
pas parce que je dis attention, il y a
un certain nombre de problématiques
migratoires, on en a parlé tout à
l'heure, c'est pas parce que je dis euh
attention euh il y a l'islam radical euh
qui est qui est un danger vital parce
que c'est un danger vital que pour
autant je mets en bloc les gens qui sont
étrangers ou qui sont musulmans. Au
contraire, il y a dans notre pays un
certain nombre de gens qui sont français
de nationalité et qui sont musulmans.
Eux, il faut absolument leur tendre la
main. Pourquoi ? Parce que eux ce sont
les cibles des islamistes. Les
islamistes sont là pour fracturer. Donc
l'islamiste et Alsouri dont je parler au
début, Abou Mousa Alouri, il dit que
pour faire monter l'islamisme, il faut
casser l'intégration, il faut
désintégrer, c'est casser l'intégration
de la jeunesse issue de l'immigration.
La logique humaine, c'est quand on
migre, on finit par euh s'intégrer et
idéalement à s'assimiler. Ce qui veut
pas dire qu'on renonce totalement à sa
culture machin et cetera, mais ça veut
dire qu'on vit à Rome vit comme les
Romains. Bon et euh Asouri dit "Les
islamistes veulent casser ça." Donc
nous, il faut qu'on fasse un
contrediscours. Ce contreddiscours, il
doit pour moi reposer sur deux choses.
La première c'est qu'il faut vraiment
tendre la main et il faut être cohérent.
Il faut autant on peut combattre
durement ceux qui respectent pas nos nos
lois et nos modes de vie. J'en parlais
tout à l'heure. Mais alors du coup ceux
qui les respectent ah ben à l'inverse
faut leur tendre la main parce que si on
refuse les premiers en disant ben oui
mais vous vous êtes contre nous et qu'on
refuse les seconds parce qu'on dit vous
vous risquez d'être contre nous
le discours. On perd d'abord on perd les
mecs et en plus on perd la cohérence du
discours. Donc et c'est pas un discours
naïf parce que j'en entends là déjà je
les entends derrière la caméra. qui
disent "Putain, le mec il est
complètement naïf machin." Non, non,
non, c'est un discours pragmatique, ce
qui est pas du tout pareil. Ça veut dire
qu'on est lucide, on fait gaffe, on est
attentif, mais on tend la main
premièrement. Et deuxièmement, il faut
redonner et ça c'est essentiel, il faut
redonner envie aux jeunes français,
quelle que soit leur origine, d'aimer
notre pays. Il faut rappeler ce que
c'est que les héros français. Ernest
Trenant disait "La France est un
héritage de gloire et de regret." Il
faut assumer la gloire, il faut aussi
assumer les regrets. Mais d'abord la
gloire. Aujourd'hui, les islamistes, ils
recrutent et d'ailleurs les de avec un
avec le niilisme, les les les criminels
aussi, ils recrute en en montrant que
nous nous n'avons plus aucune valeur,
nous ne respecterons plus rien, nous
sommes affessés, consuméristes,
individualistes, pornographe et cetera
alors que eux ils ont Luma et toute une
histoire machin. Mais nous aussi, nous
aussi on a une histoire, pardon, mais on
est donc un pays de de au racines
greco-latine, ce qui est pas rien, de
tradition judéo-chrétienne. On a c'est
la France, elle a 1000 ans. Elle a une
histoire absolument extraordinaire. Moi
quand j'ai plaidé pour la famille
d'Arnaud Beltram au aux assises, j'ai
j'ai plaidé le héros français et j'ai
dit au juges, mais j'ai dit aussi au
public, il y avit plein de monde. J'ai
dit il y a combien de gens dans la salle
qui aurait fait
qui connaissent les héros français qui
connaissent des héros français. Moi,
j'ai été bercé. On parlait de mon
patriotisme tout à l'heure. J'aurais pu
vous parler de plein de trucs, mais je
vous parle maintenant d'un truc qui pour
moi est très important, d'une chose qui
est très importante, c'est que quand
j'étais gamin, bah j'avais les livres
d'histoire, je tournais les pages et il
y avait les chevaliers, il y avait
Briard sans peur et et sans reproche, il
y avait du GClin, il y avait Jean Dark,
pardon mais Jean Dark, c'est quand même
c'est quand même hallucinant l'histoire
de Jean Dark à tout point de vue. Donc
on on a en plus là la transcendance et
cetera. Donc euh aujourd'hui euh
personne ne connaît ça. Regardez les
Jeux Olympiques, la cérémonie de 2024.
Donc on a on a mis en avant euh un
certain nombre de gens de figures de de
grandes femmes et cetera et c'est un
choix. Après on peut moi je pense que
c'est dommage parce que ça a été très
au-delà de la caricature de machin.
Est-ce que c'était W ? Est-ce que
c'était pas W c'est même pas ça le
problème. Il y aurait pu y avoir des
ouvertures, pourquoi pas mais au moins
qu'on qu'on garde les fondamentaux. Un
pays ça évolue mais mais on n'empute pas
le passer d'un coup. Et en amputant
notre passé, on se prive de tout ce qui
fait notre force et notre capacité de
séduction.
Tu as regardé la fête des Lumières à
Lyon là récemment ?
Ah bah j'ai regardé en tout cas, j'ai vu
les incidents, j'ai moi moi j'ai
halluciné les la projection sur le mur.
D'abord, il faut rappeler une chose aux
gens qui nous regardent la question,
c'est que la fête des lumières, c'est la
fête de c'est la fête de la Vierge
Marie. C'est la fête,
c'est la fête de l'Immaculée Conception
qui protège avec Fourvière qui protège
la ville de Lyon. Il y a pas une
histoire de peste avant après et que
voilà c'est que il y a il y a eu la
peste, la Vierge est apparue qu'elle a
fait un certain nombre de miracles qui
ont réussi à à sauver une partie
importante de la ville euh et donc
depuis elle est elle est euh vénérée
comme dans bien d'autres endroits dans
le monde mais notamment à Lyon. Bon donc
c'est quand même à l'origine une fête
catholique
parce que la Vierge et la basique
fourvière au-dessus de Lyon protège la
ville. Donc déjà, c'est devenu de plus
en plus une fête que qui qui a été
déracinée de son origine religieuse.
Mais là, on a quand même touché le fond
puisque d'une part il y a eu des
projections euh de de de choses pour
notamment le couscous et cetera.
C'éit de la pub ou c'était pas de la pub
?
J'ai jamais j'ai pas compris. Jeou que
j'ai pas eu le le f d'histoire mais
écoute, c'est c'est en tout cas c'était
navrant. Bon, mais ça c'était pas le
plus grave. Le plus grave, c'est la
projection de messages contre la police.
La police tue et cetera et c'est les
soulèvements de la terre. Ils l'ont
revendiqué, ils ont fait un communiqué.
Et tout à l'heure, on parlait de la
France insoumise mais il y a des députés
de la France insoumise qui ont repris le
message des soulèvements de la terre en
disant "Oui, la police tue" et cetera et
cetera. Or, la fête des Lumières, c'est
une fête publique. C'est une grande fête
dans lequelle les Lyonnais participent.
Ils sont dans la rue, ils s'amusent. Il
y a au moins 500 policiers et gendarmes
qui les protègent. Donc ils se font
insulter
alors que ils protègent. Enfin, je veux
dire et tu
as essayé de discuter avec les
soulèvements de la terre ou pas ?
Ah j'en ai jamais rencontré.
Est-ce que tu as essayé de discuter
avec eux ?
Ouais.
J'ai j'ai non j'ai jamais eu l'occasion.
Si je te fais discuter avec eux, tu
viens ?
Ah oui, bien sûr. Moi je moi je discute
avec tout le monde. J'étais invité à la
fête de Luma l'autre jour et j'y suis
pas allé parce que j'étais pas à Paris.
Mais
tu tomber
hein [rires]
faire une petite coupe de cheveux. Non
mais euh il y a il y a
tu es en train de dire que les gens de
gauche et les cheveux longs, c'est pas
sympa.
Non non non non non. C'était c'était une
petite caricature par rapport au BRS.
C'était pas une question idéologique
parce que puisqu'on parle de la fête de
l'humain, je vais quand même dire un
truc, c'est que moi je suis totalement
sidéré que euh en France alors que le
communisme a un bilan de 100 millions de
morts, alors on peut on peut discuter si
c'est 100 ou 80 mais enfin on peut pas
discuter l'échelle de grandeur. On est
le dernier pays au monde à avoir encore
un parti communiste. Moi ça c'est
quelque chose par exemple c'est facile
la Chine aussi. Ah oui pardon,
j'oubliais. Non non, j'oubliais,
j'oubliais, pardon, ils sont tellement
nombreux, tellement gros, tellement
forts, tellement puissants que je je que
j'oubliais la Chine. Pardon mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire dans les pays
européens et cetera, on aurait pu avoir
une gauche crois
que même en Russie, le Parti communiste
c'est tout petit.
Ouais. Donc c'est un truc et ils
viennent donner des leçons parce que
l'humanité donne beaucoup de leçons.
Donc c'est je je trouve ça fascinant.
Faut pas oublier quand même que
l'humanité était neutre lorsque
l'Allemagne nazie a envahi la France et
que jusqu'au pacte germano-soviétique
et que le pacte germanoviétique jusquà
l'opération Barbarossa du du 22 juin 41
où l'Allemagne d'Asie a attaqué son
allié, les Russes, les communistes
étaient quand même alliés avec les
nazis. Il faut le rappeler aux gens qui
nous regardent.
On arrive à la fin.
Tu me lis une petite page là avant.
Prends-moi une page n'importe laquelle.
Attends parce que là on va on va perdre
les les
Je voudrais terminer ce livre par trois
messages particuliers.
Ah toi tout de suite tu mets la fin du
bouquin tout de suite toi. Vas-y vas-y
fonce trois messages particuliers. Tant
pis les gens non les trois messages.
Vas-y vas-y fonce les trois messages.
Les trois messages
non le le corps du livre est très
intéressant.
Conclusion d'abord les trois messages
particuliers. D'abord je lis quand même
les deux citations en exerc de la
conclusion. L'habituel défaut de l'homme
est de ne pas prévoir leur âge par beau
temps Maiavel.
Il n'y a pas de politique qui vaille en
dehors des réalités. Charles de Gaulle,
mélange de Maabelle et de Gaulle
intéressant pour garder les yeux
ouverts. Je termine ce livre par trois
messages particuliers. Un, le premier
est destiné à tous ceux qui pourraient
être tentés de caricaturer ma pensée en
estimant que j'exagère ou pire que je
tort la réalité. À cela, je dis qu'il
aurait fallu un livre deux fois plus
long pour rentrer plus encore dans le
détail de tous les mots qui minent notre
pays. Aujourd'hui, en France, personne
n'est épargné. Je n'ai pas parlé des
vols de cuve généralisés qui causent ce
jour des dégâts considérables à
l'approvisionnement en énergie, au câble
internet, au transport ferroviaire. J'ai
pas parlé de la détresse des
agriculteurs, qu'on vo et cetera. Une
page sur ce dont j'ai pas parlé pour le
prochain livre
ou la prochaine interview.
Ou la prochaine interview.
Si nous n'agissons pas par choix, nous
serons contraints de le faire par
nécessité dans un contexte d'explosion
sociale et de violence dont les émeutes
de 2023 n'auront été que le que le hors
d'œuvre. Chacun sans que le feu couve et
que les py roman radent. Les Français ne
se sont pas révoltés après Charlie ni
après le 13 novembre. Le père Amen,
Arnaud Beltram, Samuel Paty, Dominique
Bernard, Lola, Philippine ou Thomas.
Mais l'accumulation des lâchetés rend
inéluctable la violence de la crise qui
se profile si l'autorité de l'État n'est
pas rétablie avec toute la vigueur que
la situation exige. Si l'État continue à
reculer, d'autres structures
religieuses, ethniques, mafieuses
prendront le relais de l'autorité.
Est-ce cela que nous voulons pour le
pays des Lumières ? Press plus courts.
Mon second message aux habitants des
quartiers populaires, à ceux qui
travaillent et respectent nos lois, nos
valeurs et notre mode de vie et
subissent de plein fouet les effets de
l'effondrement de l'autorité de l'État.
Je sais à quel point la majorité d'entre
eux aspirent à une vie tranquille et
sont pleinement conscients de la chance
de vivre dans un pays qui offre tant de
services publics et permet à chacun de
s'éduquer et de s'épanouir. Ils
subissent la pression des islamistes et
des trafiquants et l'oppressité par la
réputation de leur quartier d'origine
dans le regard de beaucoup. Je finis par
le troisème, c'est le plus rapide. C'est
aussi pour eux qu'il est urgent de
reprendre la main. Les pouvoirs publics
doivent faire preuve de la plus grande
fermeté à l'égard de la masse de
délinquants criminels et activistes
islamistes qui minent nos territoires,
tout en accompagnant l'ensemble des
bonnes volontés, queles que soient leurs
origines. L'autorité permettra de
rétablir la confiance que certains
d'entre eux ont perdu dans le
fonctionnement d'une République
française qui donne sa chance à tous,
qu'il soi français depuis 6 mois ou 1000
ans. Et ça c'est important qu'il soit
français depuis 6 mois ou 1000 ans. Et
je voudrais enfin m'adresser à tous ceux
qui servent notre drapeau. Je pouvais
pas finir sans eux. À vous tous, hommes
ou femmes, au contact ou étoilé, en
civil ou en uniforme, dans la lumière ou
dans l'ombre, sur notre sol ou loin de
chez nous. Mon message est très simple.
Queles que soient les épreuves qui
pourraient survenir, je ne me déroberai
pas et serai toujours présent à vos
côtés. Vive la France !
Est-ce que tu peux nous conseiller trois
livres et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? Trois livres qui ne soient
pas les tiens.
Ouais. Alors, trois livres.
Le bataillon du ciel de Joseph Kessel,
extraordinaire sur l'engagement de
français, force française libre et
cetera. Le deuxième livre, La pitié
dangereuse de Stephan Swag,
assez méconnu, très très intéressant sur
le fait que parfois la pitié peut
paralyser et peut conduire à à des à des
catastrophes. Et le troisième, je sais
qu'en ce moment tout le monde en parle,
mais il est hallucinant.
C'est l'étrange défaite de Mark Block.
Je l'ai relu l'été dernier. C'est pas
long. Vous le lisez, il y a des
paragraphes entier. Vous avez
l'impression que c'est écrit la semaine
dernière. Extraordinaire pour comprendre
comment une société peut s'effondrer de
l'intérieur. Mark Block, non seulement
il l'a vécu, il l'a vu, mais il l'a
analysé au au laser et tout le monde
devrait le relire. Un conseil pour les
jeunes générations,
comprendre que euh nous ne nous en
sortirons collectivement que si chacun
prend sa part, quel que soit le sujet,
que le monde qui vient, il va être plus
violent, mais il va être plus violent au
sens large. Il va être plus violent
économiquement, il va il va être plus
rugueux et je parle pas seulement de
violence physique, heureusement, il va
être plus rugueux. Il faut euh gagner en
autonomie et il faut faire une
combinaison qui va être très difficile
et notre génération en ville début mais
les gens qui ont qui naissent. Moi, je
vais avoir un petit fils bientôt, mon
premier petit enfant. Et en tout cas euh
les les les la génération des gens qui
ont 20 ans 30 ans et qui ont la vie
devant eux, il faut qu'il ils
réussissent la synthèse
extraordinairement difficile mais qui
est une en même temps un projet
formidable entre la capacité de survie
perso euh
en quasi en autonomie y compris sur les
choses de base et une maîtrise absolue
de l'intelligence artificielle qui va
tout changer. Donc c'est une espèce de
grand écart et ceux qui réussiront ça,
ce seront les rois du monde demain. Tibo
de Montbrial. Merci.
Merci.
[musique]